alors nous avons examiné
264 amendements il nous reste donc 5287
a examiné et donc
haut les coeurs
voilà ça vous fait sourire donc c'est
bien on est dedans quand même depuis
hier je vous le dis à fond en plus donc
je précise tout de même que je
suspendrais bien sûr nos travaux
quelques minutes avant d'aller voter en
séance publique sur le projet de loi
relatif à l'accélération de la
production d'énergie renouvelable autre
sujet tout aussi important
alors nous allons poursuivre mes chers
collègues nous n'avons pas terminé
l'article 2 et je passe tout de suite la
parole à Monsieur aviranier qui est dans
les starting blocks merci madame la
Présidente donc demandement qui vise à
appliquer une amende en cas de
non-respect d'indicateur sur la qualité
de l'emploi des seniors il semble tout à
fait justifier comme puisse aller
au-delà de du simple constat et qu'on
puisse sanctionner si c'est nécessaire
très bien Madame la rapporteur votre oui
madame la Présidente merci alors il
reste 97 amendements là dans cet article
2 on en a examiné 120 je rappelle qu'on
en a pris trois de Monsieur Viry sur le
terme senior un de Monsieur Daredevil
qui expliquait les critères rien de
Marie Pierrick saint sur le principe de
de l'index genré
c'est pourquoi dans les amendements qui
viennent pour qui sont pour des débats
qu'on a déjà eu je vais essayer de pas
trop donner de détails sauf si vous le
souhaitez donc avis défavorable
très bien
Madame hozano vous avez la parole madame
la députée
merci madame la Présidente donc je
profite de cette petite pause des
questions que tu as j'ai pour faire un
petit bilan de ces deux jours passés en
commission
alors s'il vous plaît chers collègues
certains d'entre vous espèrent que les
légitimes manifestations de position à
la réforme se transforme en révolte de
rue mais pour notre part si nous
soutenons les manifestations nous
pensons que notre travail est d'abord
parlementaire et j'insiste ce travail
parlementaire la gauche l'envisage comme
une suite de barricade successives en
forme d'amendement un travail de sape et
de retardement qui permet des numéros
d'estrade mais qui interdit d'arriver
rapidement au cœur nucléaire du sujet
quel article 7 de cette réforme donc
parler des heures de l'index des seniors
définir ce qu'est un seigneur c'est
discuter du sexe des anges seniors quand
une loi en forme de bélier social et
c'est à vous que je m'adresse va
défoncer les portes de la cité pens vous
que retarder l'étude de l'article 7 gène
la majorité et ben non pas du tout non
seulement elle la souhaite tant l'image
que vous donnez sert son discours
libéral alors au nom du groupe RN je
vous demande de cesser ce jeu des
amendements d'obstruction pour que nous
puissions aller sans retard inutile à
l'article 7 et je vous en remercie
très bien monsieur Guedj vous avez la
parole
merci madame la Présidente je crois que
nos collègues du rassemblement national
n'ont pas compris
l'ange même du débat que nous menons en
commission et que nous poursuivrons le
moment venu dans l'hémicycle parce que
voyez-vous le gouvernement nous a
expliqué à longueur de tribune et de
plateaux que il est parlementaires qui
relaient cette parole que cette index
senior constitué la mesure de sinon
compensation du moins de justice sociale
qui se glissait dans ce texte de
régression avec la mesure des deux ans
supplémentaires et nous sommes
convaincus que ce qui se passe ici et ce
qui se passe dans la rue avec la
mobilisation très forte à laquelle
certains d'entre nous ont pu participer
tout à l'heure dans les rues de Paris et
dans les nombreuses villes de provinces
dans lesquelles les rassemblements ont
eu lieu et bien ça permet de faire
bouger des lignes je le redis pour la
troisième fois mais je n'ai pas eu de
réponse j'ai l'impression que c'est plus
le Bureau Exécutif de renaissance d'hier
que la Commission des affaires
[Musique]
très bien monsieur Cyril Isaki
chers
effectivement de trouver une solution
par rapport à cette index comme vous
avez pu voir effectivement on a proposé
effectivement à un système de bonus
malus pour inciter les entreprises à
garder leur seniors malheureusement à
part vous monsieur Guedj je vois que les
autres groupes que ça soit de la nuit
pèse ou du ou du Front national nous ont
pas suivi mais ça nous empêche pas de
continuer à travailler et j'espère que
pour la séance on arrivera à trouver un
accord pour effectivement donner un peu
plus de substances à cet article
très bien monsieur Lucas merci même la
présidente à l'occasion de cette reprise
nous venons de voir ce matin il y a
quelques instants dans les rues de Paris
le résultat éclatant de votre entreprise
de pédagogie depuis des semaines puisque
plus les Français plus vous expliquer
cette réforme aux Français plus il la
comprenne et puis il la comprenne plus
il la rejette et nous ne pouvons pas
reprendre ces travaux comme si de rien
n'était il s'est passé dans le pays un
événement majeur des manifestations et
des mobilisations record dans beaucoup
de villes une mobilisation populaire
inarrêtable déterminée contre cette
réforme des retraites contre le passage
de la retraite à 64 ans et pour beaucoup
d'entre nous dont sans doute le ministre
du Travail qui lui aussi a commencé sa
vie militante en lien très fort avec le
mouvement social cela veut dire quelque
chose et c'est une démonstration
démocratique évidente alors nous voyons
et cela apparaît de jour en jour le pays
n'est pas fracturé pas divisé il est uni
il est unique contre votre réforme plus
de 7 français sur plus de 9 actifs sur
10 c'est-à-dire celles et ceux qui vont
vivre dans leur chair cette réforme et
donc je profite de cette reprise pour
inciter les députés de la majorité que
vous êtes à conseiller au gouvernement
maintenant d'apaiser le pays d'éviter
des semaines de tension et de crise et
de retirer cette réforme des retraites
très bien Madame Parmentier le coq
oui merci Madame ma présence
faire remarquer que la nupaisse déjà
depuis quelques heures et depuis hier
multiplie les petites provocations les
invictives
nous cherchent nous cherchent essayer de
de
rappeler par exemple l'histoire de du
des décisions en burex ce matin c'était
même kéké qui nous investivait monsieur
Clouet qui a ensuite raconte sur Twitter
qui a des interruptions de séance se
multiplier à notre initiative alors
qu'elles sont juste la résistante d'un
fonction de la normale ou d'interruption
qu'on doit faire à cause de leur
comportement donc moi j'aimerais
dénoncer ce mode opératoire qui consiste
à régulièrement
semer la zizanie dans le dans les débats
ou à mettre un certain nombre
d'amendements qui ne rime à rien comme
c'est depuis tout à l'heure pour ensuite
se plaindre que c'est nous qui bloque
Orions le débat
très bien monsieur Bazin
merci
je vais me concentrer sur l'amendement
parce que je crois que c'est important
qu'on puisse être sur le fond
sur les enjeux qui sont posés à l'animé
à neuf vous proposez finalement que ce
les entreprises qui méconnent et
normalement c'était l'obligation de
publication d'un index là vous voulez
dire les entreprises qui me connaissent
l'insertion professionnelle
ça me questionne en termes de
formulation et les entreprises qui
méconnent la formation tout au long de
la vie des travailleurs
sur ces deux aspects j'allais dire les
entreprises elles ont leurs salariés
actuels elles ont les salariés qu'elles
veulent recruter mais elles peuvent pas
porter ce que les salariés ont eu avant
d'intégrer leur entreprise et on connaît
dans les parcours et d'ailleurs de plus
en plus il y a des changements
d'entreprises des changements de secteur
des changements de métier et en fait la
réalité des des vies et de plus en plus
c'est de connaître plusieurs employeurs
c'est que connaître parfois plusieurs
métiers et donc je pense que de faire
porter une obligation sur les
entreprises qui méconneraient
l'insertion professionnelle je vois pas
comment ça peut être opérant et qui
méconnaîtrait la formation tout au long
de la ville et travailleurs mais je vois
bien ce que Jérôme get je veux porter et
c'est louable et je salue d'ailleurs
parce que on ne peut que se préoccuper
de l'insertion professionnelle et on
voit bien qu'il y a un certain nombre de
publics dans notre pays qui sont en
souffrance et très éloignés de l'emploi
c'est un vrai enjeu d'insertion on a une
vraie difficulté entre ceux qui s'en
occupent du côté conseil départemental
et ceux qui s'occupent de la formation
et
du développement économique côté région
on a un problème de cohérence des
politiques publiques qui sont menées et
et ça pose souci maintenant si on est là
c'est aussi parce que on a un défi c'est
assuré l'équilibre durable de notre
système de retraite par répartition ça
passera par le travail et par le
renouvellement des générations
maintenant est-ce que c'est index va
permettre le renouvellement des
générations non est-ce que c'est index
va permettre de contribuer à du travail
j'en doute j'espère qu'on pourra arriver
aux articles suivants parce que il y a
besoin d'apporter des vrais solutions à
ce problème merci bien monsieur le
député madame kéké vous avez la parole
je m'énerve pas souffrir un peu
souffrait de moi un peu merci madame la
Présidente je sais que nous sommes ici
personne ne provoque personne voilà nous
sommes là pour débatter pour débattre
pardon et de parler de la situation que
vit le peuple français ils veulent pas
de la retraite à 64 ans vous insistez au
contraire c'est vous qui provoquez
c'est vous qui provoquez
il y a pas de écoutez ce qu'on vous dit
le minimum la c'est de respecter les
gens parce que quand vous quand on
retrouve vous méprisez les gens qu'on
vous parle vous trouvez que oui on vous
provoque on ne vous provoque pas nous
sommes en train de débat d'un problème
très sérieux qui se passe en ce moment
tu sais pas en ce moment et vous faites
comme si vous n'attendez pas et vous ne
voyez pas le peuple dans la rue
non
donc quand je viens et que j'ai il y a
des choses qui me tient à cœur que je
vous parle c'est pas une provocation
voilà ne vous utilisez pas ici s'il vous
plaît commentaire sur l'amendement très
bien revenons aussi
la provoque donc dites lui aussi de
commenter sur l'amendement merci très
bien
[Musique]
désolé votre collègue s'est exprimé donc
peut-être pour tout à l'heure très bien
donc je mets aux voix cet amendement qui
a reçu un avis
défavorable de pour de la part de Madame
la rapporteur général qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté amendement
suivant madame sbahi
madame sebahi
oui non madame Rousseau très bien
écoutez défendu parce que là j'ai pas
j'ai pas son amendement donc défendu
merci pour la concision des femmes dans
leur rapporteur général des favorable
des favorables oui monsieur Delaporte
oui c'est excellent amendement du groupe
écologiste
viser à rendre effective la sanction
administrative en manière en matière de
non-respects des objectifs en matière
d'emploi des seniors bon au-delà de cet
amendement de fond qui est en effet
nécessaire parce que comment voulez-vous
et on l'a dit ce matin avoir un index si
celui-ci ne veut pas être appliqué
vraiment donc voilà c'est un amendement
de précision rédactionnel qui montre à
la fois notre intention de travailler
sur le fond contrairement à ce que
disait madame Parmentier le coq tout à
l'heure qui m'a particulièrement choquée
parce que ça ne correspondait pas à la
tonalité des débats que j'ai vu depuis
hier soir qui sont des débats vraiment
sérieux et les Français et les Français
que j'ai rencontré dans la manifestation
tout à l'heure nous remercier d'ailleurs
pour la qualité des débats que nous
avons pour porter des sujets de fonds
parce que c'est aussi un encouragement
pour celles et ceux qui manifestent
aujourd'hui à aller dans la rue dire au
gouvernement que eux aussi sont
sensibles aux arguments que nous
développons s'il vous plaît à
l'amendement alors hier on avait
vraiment
vous allez voir ce que vous allez voir
voilà manifestation grève et là
maintenant on a le commentaire de la
grève moi j'aimerais bien qu'on avance
sur le texte je crois qu'on est tous ici
et tout ici pour avancer sur le texte
voilà franchement
je vous donne la parole pour intervenir
sur les amendements et en fait vous
intervenez par rapport à ce qui se passe
à l'extérieur de l'Assemblée nationale
très bien non mais franchement c'est
j'ai l'impression qu'on ne va pas
avancer là-dessus alors que certains
demandent effectivement à ce que nous
avons franchement alors je mets aux voix
j'ai madame Meslin qui souhaite
intervenir madame Meslin et ensuite
madame dubrechirat oui merci madame la
Présidente je vais parler sur
l'amendement quand on voit parler
d'applications de l'autorité
administrative on se dit que on a déjà
beaucoup beaucoup avancé dans le terme
des sanctions mais quand même il
faudrait qu'on se demande deux secondes
de quoi parle-t-on on parle des 62 64
ans
ce sont deux générations d'environ 750
000 personnes de ces 700 de ce million
et demi de personnes il faut retrancher
ceux qui sont en emploi ceux qui sont au
chômage ceux qui sont en invalidité et
ceux qui sont déjà retraités il est très
difficile de trouver les chiffres exacts
portant sur cette tranche d'âge en loque
ça doit être entre 500 000 fourchettes
très basses à 800 000 personnes et on
voudrait que ce soit ces personnes là
qui portent la totalité du problème
alors que nous avons plus de 30 millions
d'actifs cela déjà est disproportionné
et que se passe-t-il il se passe alors
que le corps avait parfaitement prévenu
de la situation en 2010 de même qu'il
vous prévient de la situation en 2030 le
corps avait parfaitement prévu qu'il
faudrait allonger vous aviez madame la
rapportrice et les membres de l'exécutif
vous avez eu 11 ans pour faire des
propositions autre qu'un indicateur
entre nous soit dit c'est vraiment très
court alors compte tenu de l'absence
totale de propositions concernant cette
tranche d'âge 62 64 ans je vous demande
simplement à tout le moins si vous ne
souhaitez pas retirer cette ce projet de
faire un moratoire et de nous présenter
enfin des solutions pour les 62 64 ans
plutôt que de les envoyer au travail
alors que 30 millions d'actifs ne
travaillent que 1600 heures par an je
vous remercie et bien donc je mets aux
voix cet amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui contre il est rejeté amendement
pouvant être mis en discussion commune
alors il y en a plusieurs madame
Rousseau pour le 38 57
merci madame la Présidente alors en fait
c'est toujours cette même histoire de
rendre l'index coercitif et puis surtout
que ça soit suivi de sanction alors
évidemment là non texte de loi il est
prévu 1% 1% on se dit c'est un index va
varier c'est un index sur une main c'est
pas grand chose en fait alors que ça
pourrait être 30 % des rémunérations et
que là ce serait véritablement incitatif
pour les entreprises et si on s'attaque
et si on veut s'attaquer vraiment au
fléau du non-emploi ou du sous-emploi
des seniors et bien il faut se donner
les moyens d'arriver aux objectifs que
nous nous fixons nous-mêmes et donc 30%
et bien mieux que 1% donc nous vous
proposons de substituer à l'aliné à neuf
le taux de 1% à celui de 30% madame la
députée est-ce que vous acceptez de
défendre l'ensemble de vos amendements
parce qu'une fois on a 30 ensuite on a
29 ensuite on a 28 on a ensuite désolé
parce qu'en fait on va aller on va les
défendre
[Musique]
un nouveau proposons après un amendement
de repli qui ne soit pas donc à 30% mais
à 29% parce qu'on se doutait bien que
30% ça allait susciter chez vous
quelques réactions vu la difficulté que
vous avez à encadrer l'activité des
entreprises et à mettre des conditions
dans leur fonctionnement mais si vous
n'acceptez pas 29 % nous vous proposons
alors 28%, ce qui permettrait quand même
d'être dans un chiffre qui serait
véritablement incitatif mais qui ne
serait toute seule
pas coercitive coercitif si toutefois
28% vous estimez que c'est trop
important alors nous pouvons évidemment
descendre à 27%, ce qui permettrait
quand même d'avoir un véritable une
véritable action sur l'index mais sur
l'effet de l'index sur l'activité mais
bon si 27 n'est toujours pas possible et
bien il y a 26 ou 25 évidemment mais
nous n'imaginons pas un instant que vous
pourriez descendre en dessous de 15%
puisque si vous êtes sincère dans votre
combat pour faire en sorte qu'il y ait
un emploi et qu'il y a un taux d'emploi
en chez les chez les plus enfin chez les
seniors et bien votre sincérité se
mesure en fait à la hauteur du
pourcentage que vous accepterez en
compensation de d'une non efficacité sur
la politique d'emploi de ces seniors à
l'intérieur de chaque entreprise donc
nous vous en fait ce qu'on va mesurer là
par cette série d'amendements c'est quel
est votre capacité vraiment à encadrer
très bien Madame c'est votre capacité à
vraiment prendre en compte et à rendre
cet index coercitif très bien Madame A
député donc vous avez défendu le 348
d'aller jusqu'au 858 vous êtes ah oui
d'accord très bien
OK
attendez je et après je pense que ça va
être madame tailler paulian qui va
soutenir les autres aucun problème
alors attendez dans la liasse
d'amendement j'ai monsieur avant madame
vous êtes allés jusqu'au 840 11% c'est
ça madame madame la députée parce que
j'estime qu'en dessous de 15% ce serait
un dessin mais on va voir comment vous
allez voter
donc 15%
alors oui mais alors madame madame
madame la députée dans le fil conducteur
de la de la discussion l'amendement
suivant c'est celui que vous proposez et
vous proposez à 14% donc je vous donne
la parole
oui mais moi je propose que ce soit
porté par d'autres parce que je sens
bien que j'ai énerve un peu cette
commission alors ce serait quand même
bien que ça puisse être porter aussi par
de Monsieur Lucas est-il là pour pouvoir
le défendre oui
comme il n'a pas été signé par tout le
monde je vous le dis je l'ai pas signé
mais oui si vraiment vous voulez que je
continue donc alors bon 15% c'est pas si
je veux madame vous avez déposé des
amendements vous devez les défendre non
mais je vais continuer à les défendre
défendu non non non non non pas défendu
non non non non non non non
parce que le 15 % c'est déjà fait faible
bon c'est faible mais on pourrait se
rendre sur le 34 décembre en dessous
madame la députée madame la députée nous
sommes sur le 38 39 j'ai bien compris
pour le 15 % ça y est c'est fait c'est
pour ça que maintenant vous avez proposé
d'autres amendements avec d'autres taux
aussi voulez-vous les défendre
n'étant peut-être pas encore
suffisamment
suffisamment convaincant à vos yeux on
descend à 14% mais 14% vraiment là ce
serait ce serait insulte fait au seniors
mais on peut aussi descendre à 13% selon
le l'amendement 842 on peut aller à 12 %
avec le 38 41 descendra 11 pour le 38 40
et après je laisse la parole à Monsieur
Lamia merci et je donne la parole à
Monsieur Monet merci madame la
Présidente nous on a un peu moins
ambitieux on propose de descendre à 10%
très bien merci Monsieur
[Musique]
Monet ensuite amendement
identique j'ai monsieur aviranier
monsieur Delaporte aucun problème il
faut en effet relever le régime des
sanctions le plafond de l'amende nous on
suggère 10% ses raisonnable et c'est un
bon amendement de compromis
très bien alors
également celui
identique le 47 89 de madame panot
oui allez-y madame la députée
oui
nous aimerions également discuter de la
façon dont on pénalise en cas de non
publication par les entreprises de
l'index seniors en portant par exemple à
20% de la masse salariale au lieu de 1%
actuellement parce que pour le moment le
but affiché de ces articles est très
flou et très peu très probablement sans
impact sur l'emploi des seniors vu le
contenu de l'exposé des motifs donc la
création d'un tel index a pour objectif
d'objectiver la place des seniors en
entreprise d'assurer la transparence à
matière de gestion des âges je t'en prie
Antoine si tu veux passer deux valoriser
les bonnes pratiques en la matière et
d'ailleurs c'est le secrétaire
confédéral de la CGT qui s'exprime en
là-dessus n'est pas vraiment convaincu
par ce qui est proposé jusqu'à
maintenant par l'index puisque tous les
syndicats s'accordent pour dire que
cette index est
inefficace la réalité c'est que les
plans de départ volontaires des
entreprises concernent avant tous les
seniors en leur propose une indemnité en
leur disant qu'il pourrait toucher
l'assurance chômage sans devoir chercher
un nouvel emploi de plus c'est prix au
départ c'est toujours lui qui parle de
plus ses prix au départ ne sont pas
payés par les actionnaires mais par les
aides publiques versées aux entreprises
un index senior ni changera rien même
avec des sanctions il n'y aura aucune
incitation pour que les entreprises
bougent on le voit avec l'index pour
l'égalité femme homme qui malgré les
sanctions n'a pas réduit les inégalités
salariales il faut des mesures
contraignantes comme une surcotisation
pour les entreprises se séparant des
travailleurs les plus âgés ou encore la
soumission de l'octroi des aides
publiques 157 milliards par an au
maintien des seniors dans l'emploi
au-delà de cette mesure technique il
faut traiter la question de l'emploi des
seniors et du sens du travail et ça ne
passe pas par une réforme régressive sur
les retraites il conclut en disant il
conclut en disant nous devons
reconsidérer la place des seniors dans
l'entreprise et la santé au travail très
bien Madame la Députée monsieur
aviranier pour le 856
défendu merci monsieur le député madame
monsieur Petavy pour le 300013 oui
madame allez-y
Madame ou Monsieur
moi j'avais monsieur abiranier vous
m'avez défendu monsieur petaby oui
donc on a eu un grand débat ce matin sur
cette question des contraintes la
nécessité ou pas de mettre des
contraintes et donc on a entendu dans
vos rangs l'action on mettait des
contraintes ça allait plutôt être
négative donc sur sur l'emploi bon ce
serait bien d'expliquer quand même à
tous ces seniors à toutes ces personnes
là qui aujourd'hui sont ni dans l'emploi
ni à la retraite comment vous allez un
petit peu expliquer un petit peu leur
situation et comment on va pouvoir
arranger l'emploi des seniors et sans
contrainte sérieuse on arrivera à rien
donc là franchement on vous demande
encore une fois 10% ce n'est pas énorme
non plus mais ça permet
d'inciter fortement merci
très bien Madame Rousseau
vraiment encore une fois à sanctionner
les entreprises qui ne respecteraient
pas les leur plan d'action sur
l'augmentation de l'emploi des seniors
mais bon on se dit quand même que 10 %
c'est acceptable par vous et on y croit
vraiment très bien j'ai plusieurs
demandes de parole mes chers collègues
j'ai toute une liasse
d'amendement qui sont en discussions
communes donc c'est pour ça que je ne
vous donne pas la parole on finit
effectivement la défense des amendements
et ensuite je vous donnerai la parole
donc voilà mais ils sont nombreux très
bien donc j'en suis à Madame Garin avec
le 63 55 oui dans la même veine de ce
qui a été dit dans mes collègues par mes
collègues de dans la même veine de ce
qu'on discute depuis ce matin tout ce
qu'on demande c'est effectivement qu'il
y a une certaine notion de contrainte
que ce soit pas simplement de
l'affichage et du maquillage parce que à
nouveau je rappelle que il y a certaines
entreprises sont demandeuses et que
c'est contrainte qui peuvent nous
pousser à avoir des changements sur le
temps long et que là finalement ce que
vous nous l'expliquez très bien vous
essayez d'impulser une forme de une
impulsion on va dire culturelle dans le
monde de l'entreprise mais au-delà de
l'impulsion on a peut-être pas le temps
d'attendre il faut aller plus loin et
donc mettre des contraintes et 10 % ça
nous semble vraiment peu donc on espère
que vous très bien très bien alors cette
fois-ci j'ai trois amendements
identiques de 10% nous passons à 9%.
donc monsieur Petavy
alors est-ce que ceci amène à long débat
monsieur Petavy après avoir défendu si
vous voulez oui si vous insistez on peut
faire long et
on aime le débat parce que c'est
important le débat justement et
effectivement toutes les personnes qui
étaient dans la rue aujourd'hui s'il
vous plaît
mais justement c'est pour les entendre
ce sont justement tous ces seniors qui
sont dans la rue et donc c'est pour eux
je salue quand même les 1800 qu'il y
avait à Sarlat aujourd'hui à 15h et
voilà c'est bien
sarlatana voilà et donc voilà donc s'il
vous plaît entendez qu'il faut
au moins 9% si vous voulez pas les 10 au
moins 9 s'il vous plaît très bien merci
monsieur le député madame Rousseau de
10% nous passons à neuf
neuf c'est moins de 10 mais c'est
plus que 8 et on se dit bien que
très bien Madame la base de cet
argumentation enfin allez vous nous
écoutez madame madame Garand pareil pour
9 % nous passons de 10 à 9 madame Garin
vous avez la parole oui dans la même
veine on comprend que ça vous agace un
petit peu cette dégradoles mais
finalement non mais elle est aussi un
petit peu à l'image de la dégringolade
du dialogue social en France et du fait
qu'on est on a l'impression de pas être
entendu donc donc oui on poursuit très
bien alors cette fois-ci j'ai à nouveau
trois amendements identiques nous
passons de 9% à 8%. donc monsieur Petavy
vous défendez l'amendement à 8%
, monsieur
Petavy oui vous avez la parole monsieur
le député merci
c'est pas très sympa
pour les 8 %
Monsieur petavi Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE s'il
vous plaît oui oui bon on continue
puisque c'est pas possible avec les
neufs on aimerait bien arriver bon
sérieusement on voudrait que vous
arriviez quand même à entendre qu'il y a
un enjeu important un besoin et donc
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît à vendre
que vous proposiez a priori peut-être en
séance vous allez peut-être reprendre un
chiffre là-dedans mais ce serait bien
qu'on puisse avoir une réponse là qu'on
puisse en discuter sérieusement très
bien et ensuite madame Rousseau sur les
8% à 8% c'est à peu près le taux de
soutien à votre réforme dans l'opinion
publique donc là on se dit que quand
même c'est un plancher quoi vous pouvez
pas aller voilà très bien Madame Garin
l'amendement sur les le taux d'huile
pour cent mais sur les 8% moi j'en
profite aussi pour saluer les 45000
manifestants qui étaient à Lyon
aujourd'hui
très bien nous en revenons à
l'amendement s'il vous plaît alors s'il
vous plaît alors j'ai à nouveau trois
amendements identiques nous passons vous
l'avez deviné de 8% à 7%, Monsieur
Petavy l'amendement sur les taux de 7%
. monsieur Petavy vous avez la parole
vous encore oui oui encore
bon cette
franchement les Français nous regardent
et là c'est pas bien joyeux je vous le
dis non
ce qui est juste il vous regarde et
justement avec le monde aujourd'hui qui
est présent oui encore encore il faut
l'entendre il faut le voir et donc c'est
important de pouvoir prendre la mesure
et l'importance là d'arriver quand même
à avoir peut-être 7% très bien merci
monsieur le député madame Rousseau votre
amendement sur les 7% allez 7%, c'est le
taux de chômage sur lequel s'est fondé
le corps pour faire ses hypothèses parce
que précisément l'hypothèse du
gouvernement à 5,5 et a été jugé peu
crédible par lui donc 7% on se dit que
finalement c'est un chiffre qui est
raisonnable et qu'il faudrait soutenir
et que par ailleurs je pense que les
Français et Françaises comprennent très
bien pourquoi nous faisons obstruction à
un projet de loi un projet de loi
décidément tu précisément j'ai
l'impression dans la rue
[Applaudissements]
très bien Madame la Députée poursuivait
mes chers collègues
madame la députée s'il vous plaît seul
madame la députée à la parole
madame la députée madame Rousseau vous
avez fini madame gara allez-y
mais mais bien sûr que les Français nous
regardent mais les Français ce qu'ils
voient c'est votre brutalité et en fait
évidemment
on peut parler calmement seul madame la
député à la parole s'il vous plaît mes
chers collègues s'il vous plaît madame
Garin vous avez la parole
je m'exprime que en mon nom au nom de
mon groupe je parle pas pour les autres
groupes mais il y a il y a quand même
non mais vous pouvez pas nous reprocher
en fait de faire notre travail
parlementaire vous pouvez pas nous
reprocher vous pouvez pas nous reprocher
d'être l'écho de la rue en fait et des
gens qui se sont mobilisés aujourd'hui
qui se sont mobilisés le 19 janvier on
utilise tous les outils qui sont à notre
disposition et si ça vous pose problème
c'est votre problème parce que c'est
notre rôle en fait c'est notre rôle de
porter la parole des personnes qui nous
ont élu et vous pouvez ne pas être
d'accord sur la méthode mais vous n'avez
pas le droit de mépriser les gens que
nous représentons
très bien Madame Rousseau pour le taux
assis non pardon madame gara vient de
s'exprimer sur le 6%
dans c'était le 7 maintenant on est sur
le 6 alors j'ai trois amendements encore
sur le on passe de 7 % à 6 %. donc
monsieur Petavy
défendu monsieur Petavy non non pas
défendu
alors presque tous les cadres ont
entendu parler d'au moins donc un
dispositif mais ce n'est le cas que de
six ouvriers ou ouvrières sur 10 donc
voilà celle-ci pour ça pour ceux qui
sont informés donc de dispositifs pour
la formation des seniors
bien monsieur le député madame Rousseau
le 6% sur le taux de 6% mais 6%
d'ailleurs j'en discutais avec
l'ensemble des personnes qui étaient
tout à l'heure Place d'Italie et ils
étaient ils disaient que quand même il y
avait il y avait nécessité de de faire
en sorte que cette réforme ne passe pas
ou qu'elle passe via l'autoritarisme du
gouvernement et donc on se disait que 6
% ben voilà ça permettait au moins de le
mettre en lumière très bien Madame Garin
défendu très bien Madame la Députée
monsieur Monet un amendement sur 5%
oui madame la Présidente on peut dire
que c'est au vu du débat un amendement
de compromis mais quand même moi ce qui
me marque là dans la nature de débats et
à travers cette réforme
il n'y a pas de débat mais par contre il
faudra arrêter de faire preuve d'une
certaine condescendance quand on
s'exprime et nous les séparer dans de
bonnes conditions
je trouve que ce que ça traduit ce débat
c'est selon nous avec votre effort vous
êtes capable d'infliger des choses
difficiles au monde du travail c'est
perçu comme ça que vous le contestez ou
non c'est perçu comme ça et c'est pour
ça qu'il y a des gens dans la rue qui
comptaient cette réforme et dès qu'on
demande un peu de contrainte au monde
aux entreprises c'est systématique
systématiquement refusé c'est dans la
logique de votre effort vous vous mettez
à contribution toujours les mêmes
très bien monsieur le député alors j'ai
des amendements
identiques plusieurs on passe aussi à 5%
donc monsieur aviranier oui merci madame
la Présidente également en amendement à
100% et pareil moi je ne pensais
vraiment pour les gens qui manifestent à
Saint-Gaudens 2000 personnes dans une
ville dix mille habitants c'est pas rien
[Applaudissements]
pour le taux de 5% alors 5% ben je pense
moi au 5 milliards de cadeaux aux riches
avec la suppression de l'ISF et donc ça
pourrait être un bon symbole voilà
très bien Madame Rousseau le taux à 5%.
alors 5% mais précisément le déficit
maximal prévu de du système de retraite
c'est 12 milliards et le corps estime
que ce sera 5 milliards le taux
l'augmentation des dépenses de santé
liées à l'incapacité à l'invalidité au
RSA et les dépenses sociales donc 5
milliards de dépenses de santé
supplémentaires valent bien 5% de
contraintes sur les entreprises nous
vous
convaincons vraiment enfin nous allons
essayer de vous convaincre de voter ce
taux madame Garin pour le taux à 5% 5%
c'est deux fois moins de ce sur quoi on
est parti on est parti 10%. moi
j'entends sur les rangs derrière que
quand on défend de manière plus brève ce
serait un aveu de faiblesse mais je
crois qu'il faut sortir un peu de vos
représentations du pouvoir et de la
politique où tout n'est que rapport de
force ici on représente les gens comme
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
mais si si j'ai entendu sur les rangs
derrière moi que dire défendu ce serait
oh il y a de la faiblesse mais en fait
tout le monde n'est pas dans un rapport
politique justement à être le plus fort
donc c'est
s'il vous plaît
mes chers collègues
madame Guérin
seul madame la députée à la parole s'il
vous plaît madame Garin vous avez fini
madame je vous remercie je voulais juste
dire qu'effectivement ça traduit une
vision assez pacéiste de la politique et
c'est bien triste pour vos rangs
très bien donc tout le monde a défendu
du coup c'est moi qui m'y perds on a
fait le 4 non on n'a pas fait les 4%
voilà donc on repart avec Monsieur
abiranier défendu monsieur le député oui
madame la Présidente quatre pour cent il
vient d'à côté très bien
franchement 4 % c'est le minimum
syndical quand les entreprises ont été
exonérées de 160 milliards d'euros très
bien Madame Rousseau 4%
4 % qu'est ce que vous voulez moi j'ai
commencé à 30% là on est à 4 % et je
sens quand même toujours pas convaincu
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire de plus là
vraiment non mais elle a vraiment enfin
voilà
on peut pas descendre en dessous vous
pouvez pas défendre descendre en dessous
très bien alors ensuite madame Guérin
pour le l'amendement avec un taux à 4
défendu
ma 4% c'est pas grand chose quand on
sait qu'il y a une moitié des gens qui
ne sont plus en emploi au moment
d'ouvrir leurs droits chez les seniors à
ce moment-là alors non me dit qu'on peut
pas descendre en dessous si j'ai à 3% et
Monsieur aviranier
non je le défends pas trop pour ça
vous ne défendez pas donc il est retiré
monsieur le député
3% c'est le déficit imposé le déficit
maximal imposé par l'Europe au nom de au
nom duquel cette réforme des retraites
est faite au fond et que là on voit les
vrais visages c'est à dire que parce que
la vérité de motivation de cette réforme
pas évidemment pas de régler l'emploi
des seniors mais juste de régler un
problème de déficit madame madame la
députée vous m'avez dit tout à l'heure
vous ne vouliez pas descendre en dessous
de 4 je vous repose la question il est
défendu pas défendu vous m'avez rien de
le défendre et je vous dis que c'est le
déficien descendu en dessous de 4%.
merci Madame Garin vous avez la parole
pour l'amendement à 3% je n'ai rien à
ajouter après l'excellente défense de ma
collègue Rousseau très bien je vous
remercie et bien nous pouvons encore
descendre en dessous de 3%, il y a 2 %
monsieur aviranier
oui madame la Présidente de pour cent on
est d'accord
si on regarde le taux d'imposition des
plus pauvres et on se dit que 2%
d'imposition des 0,01% et bien c'est la
honte du gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron
très bien alors ensuite madame Garin 2 %
madame Guérin s'il vous plaît cher
collègue
mes chers
madame Garin défendu très bien merci
Madame Garin monsieur d'arriville pour
au moins égal à 1% un amendement
l'idée c'est que ça fasse pas moins de
1%, parce que tel que c'est écrit dans
le texte ça pourrait faire moins de 1 %
nous on dit le minimum c'est quand même
important très bien merci mes chers
collègues donc nous allons demander la
vie à notre rapporteur général chers
Stéphanie merci madame la Présidente
donc ce texte prévoit un plafond qui
correspond à 1% de la masse salariale de
l'entreprise en cas de non publication
ce qui est déjà élevé et je voudrais
dire on a parlé longuement sur les
différents taux qui pourraient être mis
mais en fait l'important c'est quand
même que il n'y ait même pas les 1%
parce que s'il n'y avait même pas les
1%, ça voudrait dire que l'index
républié donc l'objectif de cette de
cette index et de cette sanction c'est
qu'elle ne soit pas appliquée d'ailleurs
dans l'index égalité professionnel c'est
plus de 90% des grandes entreprises qui
l'ont publié enfin en auditionné le
directeur de la Caisse nationale
d'assurance vieillesse qui a rappelé en
audition que cette pénalité était déjà
très importante et que les entreprises
seraient ainsi fortement incité à
publier la Dex c'est donc un avis
défavorable
très bien alors je j'ai quelques
demandes d'intervention alors pour le
rassemblement national je suis désolé
mais j'ai vu plusieurs mains se lever il
y a qu'un intervenant mettez-vous
d'accord
allez-y madame merci madame la
Présidente écoutez il y a une réalité
aujourd'hui c'est que le report de l'âge
légal maintient les personnes âgées dans
le chômage vous qui aimez les
comparaisons notre pays a un taux de
chômage des saignants les plus hauts
d'Europe
seulement 30% des 60 64 ans ont toujours
un emploi et à cela vous n'avez qu'une
seule réponse un index ce n'est pas
sérieux votre réforme aura un impact
c'est-à-dire prolonger le temps de
chômage des 62 64 ans aggravins ainsi
les dépenses de l'assurance maladie et
de l'assurance chômage pourquoi ne pas
plutôt envisager que la faute originelle
vient du report de l'âge légal plutôt
que créer des mesures coercitives contre
les entreprises qui ne seront ni
appliquées ni respectés merci beaucoup
très bien
ensuite madame taillée Paulin paulian
pardon
vous avez le micro
est-ce que ça marche
merci madame la Présidente
c'est vrai que on pourrait se dire que
la principale raison de ses amendements
c'est de poser une question qui taraude
les Françaises et les Français qui
voient
finalement
leurs impôts soit stagner soit augmentée
par le biais de la TVA sur l'inflation
je rappelle que les Françaises et les
français payent de plus en plus de TVA
que l'État par ailleurs
que ça permet à l'état de fournir son
budget
et puis d'un autre côté on demande aux
entreprises de publier
des indicateurs et c'est la seule chose
qu'on leur demande dans tout ce projet
de loi finalement puisqu'il ne cotisa
rien il ne participent à rien ils ne
sont responsables de rien alors même que
dans le fondement de la sécurité sociale
la sécurité sociale elle est basée sur
un accord de toute la société pour une
protection sociale qui fondent la
République et c'est donc à la fois la
participation des entreprises la
participation des salariés qui
travaillent ensemble appelé à la gestion
de ses fonds or dans ce projet de loi on
ne demande rien aux entreprises rien on
dirait qu'elle regarde passer les trains
que ça ne les concerne pas et bien si
cela les concerne et il faut que dans
notre société nous reprenions un peu ce
débat quelle est la place des
entreprises dans le financement de notre
système de protection sociale au regard
de ce sujet il nous a semblé important
de dire que OUI pour cette mesure hyp
qui n'en est même pas une il faut
obliger les entreprises et de manière
assez symbolique et forte à publier
cette index parce que si en plus elle ne
le publiait pas parce qu'il n'y a pas de
sanction et bien voilà le résultat de
votre politique le néant monsieur Léo
man à la parole
pardon
aucun souci allez-y oui tandis que le
rassemblement national et Renaissance
défilé ensemble à la buvette 500 000
manifestants défilés à Paris dans les
rues et 12000 à Chambéry pour dénoncer
le fanatisme libéral de votre loi de
riche pour les riches et dont l'horizon
et le démantèlement de l'ensemble de
notre système social de santé et de
protection sociale à la française
mais j'en viens à la demande on a ici on
a besoin de se poser la question du
droit et du devoir là finalement votre
loi impose à des gens qui sont usés
parfois brisés cassés d'aller travailler
c'est ça va être un devoir pour eux de
trouver du travail et finalement il
n'est compensé par aucun devoir de
l'entreprise de les embaucher dans vos
pensées bien que la plupart vont les
laisser comme c'est déjà le cas
aujourd'hui en fin de carrière à partir
de 55 ans l'employabilité des seniors va
être extrêmement compliqué et donc vous
voyez bien que ici on a le devoir qui
est imposé aux gens de travailler
jusqu'à 64 ans mais il y a en face
aucune coercition qui les oblige qui
oblige les entreprises finalement à leur
réserver des emplois c'est la première
incohérence qui est complètement
aberrante et qui fait que votre loi déjà
mériterait d'être retiré mais l'autre
incohérence que j'aimerais vous faire
pointer du doigt c'est l'offre et la
demande est-ce que vous croyez
sérieusement que c'est parce que vous
allez
imposer du travail à des personnes qui
sont déjà dans un âge avancé les seniors
vous allez les obliger à travailler
est-ce que et donc à produire mais à
produire pour qui pourquoi donc
finalement vous vous pensez que en
augmentant l'offre et bien la demande va
apparaître mais la demande elle
apparaîtra pas puisque vous avez refusé
l'augmentation du SMIC déjà pour
commencer donc la demande globale de des
consommateurs français elle est au même
niveau aujourd'hui qu'elle était il y a
un an puisque de toute façon les
salaires ont pratiquement pas augmenté
et parfois depuis plusieurs années donc
votre loi il est complètement
incohérente et donc il faut absolument
obliger les entreprises à être
contraintes à embaucher des seniors
voilà pourquoi le taux de 30% et tout à
fait justifié
merci madame la Présidente là je vous
avoue que je suis consterné on a eu des
on a eu des excès de prise de parole
jusque là on a eu des provocations ce
matin et là on a l'obstruction
qui veut cacher une absence
d'argumentaire il y a des il y a des
enjeux il y a des anges on arrête vous
auriez pu en choisir un un taux un taux
de sanction un taux d'amende et bien
argumenté dessus on a des enjeux de
pérennité de notre système financier en
matière de retraite est-ce qu'on le
mesure ça ne sera plus un système pas
répartition on peut faire collectivement
ce choix là qu'est-ce qui c'est écrit
parfaitement dans le rapport du corps
les pensions vont baisser donc vous vous
engagez clairement à ce que les pensions
soient baissées de 25% à l'horizon d'une
vingtaine d'années par rapport au reste
des au reste des actifs on aurait pu
parler
on aurait pu parler de la place des
femmes dans le système de retraite de
l'incohérence de l'incohérence de tout
un tas de règles de l'incohérence de
tout un tas de règles entre les
différents régimes de retraite on aurait
pu parler de sujets sérieux posément et
de noter que passer de 62 à 74 ans c'est
un effort il faut essayer
c'est un effort on pourrait aussi
expliquer pourquoi se demander pourquoi
il y a pas un pays qui nous touche qui a
un âge de départ en traite aussi bas
qu'en France pour être questionner sur
ces sujets là
donc on pourrait se poser toutes les
questions vous vous préférez l'excès on
peut aussi se demander pourquoi on est à
STO à ce dossier bas d'emploi des
seigneurs vous avez il y a eu un certain
nombre de gouvernements
il y a eu un certain nombre de
gouvernement qui dans les 20 dernières
années ont mis en place des programmes
de prérequettes pour faire des seniors
une variable d'ajustement nous voulons
remettre ce sujet dans le débat pour
refaire des seniors une richesse plutôt
qu'une variable d'ajustement on pouvait
aborder ce sujet avec un certain une
certaine envie une certaine pour
valoriser les choses plutôt que de
limiter un débat aussi stérile que vous
avez pu faire jusque là très bien merci
monsieur le député madame Le Nabour vous
avez la parole
je vous donne allez-y merci madame la
Présidente j'ai cru pendant 10 minutes
me trouver dans une salle des ventes aux
enchères il vous manquait plus que le
marteau madame la Présidente alors à la
nupes vous n'avez de cesse de taper sur
les entreprises et de vouloir toujours
ajouter des contraintes la plus grande
contrainte des entreprises aujourd'hui
ce sont les tensions de recrutement je
suis sur un territoire à 3,5 de chômage
et nous sommes nombreux à être dans des
territoires qui avoisinent le plein
emploi
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui les entreprises
elles ont augmenté les salaires elle se
réinterroge sur leur mode de recrutement
et s'oriente vers des profils comme les
seniors comme les personnes en situation
de handicap comme les jeunes elles
améliorent les conditions de travail et
le dialogue social alors elles en sont
peut-être pas tout au même niveau mais
en tous les cas nous nous leur demandons
là un effectivement un de publier un
index il faudra suivre les effets de cet
index mais leur demandons aussi d'agir
sur la prévention d'agir sur la
formation et bien sûr le plus beau
levier pour
réduire pour par exemple pour pardon
pour augmenter le taux d'emploi des
seniors c'est et bien de travailler pour
le plein emploi et puis je rappelle un
dernier chiffre c'est que à chaque fois
qu'une réforme des retraites a été mise
en base et qu'elle a et qu'elle a décalé
l'âge de départ à la retraite le taux
d'emploi le taux d'emploi des seniors a
augmenté
très bien monsieur Bazin
merci madame la Présidente
finalement c'est index ça peut
apparaître comme une fausse bonne idée
et on a
on a un problème alors déjà je voudrais
qu'on fasse attention au discours
caricaturaux parce que moi je connais
des entreprises dans ma circonscription
qui n'ont pas attendu un index pour
recruter des seniors et et je crois
qu'il faut qu'on fasse très attention ça
se passe d'ailleurs avec des dispositifs
très attendus le message qu'on doit
porter et qui à mon avis un vrai en jeu
c'est ce qu'on veut que les personnes et
que tout incite à partir plus tôt ou
est-ce qu'on peut adapter les choses
pour leur permettre à un moment de
continuer dans les meilleures conditions
à pouvoir travailler apporter leur
expérience à transmettre on a un
problème entre la décéquation entre les
offres d'emploi et les demandes et qu'en
fait une entreprise elle reçoit un
certain nombre de CV c'est pas toujours
des personnes
âgées qui candidatent d'ailleurs ça on
ne le maîtrise pas forcément et on a un
enjeu aussi de mise en oeuvre
opérationnelle sur cette index parce que
la réalité en fonction des secteurs va
être très différente on a un enjeu
d'adaptation des postes en fonction
d'âge et c'est POS varie en fonction des
secteurs en fonction des branches en
faire en fonction des types d'entreprise
et donc on a un enjeu aussi
d'anticipation tous ces enjeux là c'est
pas l'index qui va y répondre il y a un
besoin d'adapter bien avant la question
de la gessénia et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui quand on a seulement 35,5
% des 60 64 ans j'allais dire le mal se
signe se situe plutôt c'est comment on
imagine des reconversions des des
acquisitions de nouveaux métiers à des
moments qui sont plus adaptés à un âge
avançant et donc je suis pas sûr que
l'index soit l'alpha et l'oméga une
politique et je suis pas sûr que de
rajouter des sanctions sur la
publication d'un index va apporter des
solutions efficaces sur la réalité de
l'amélioration du taux d'emploi ce qui
doit nous concentrer c'est trouver des
solutions pour améliorer le taux
d'emploi créer les conditions pour que
ça soit possible et facile très bien
monsieur le député monsieur Monet vous
avez la parole
très rapidement dans le débat il s'agit
pas de dire que les entreprises ne sont
pas vertueuses il s'agit d'être capable
de donner des commandements à ce que
tout le monde contribue il s'agit de
dire que les contraintes elles soient
données à tout le monde le salarié a des
contraintes quand il ne remplit pas
certaines obligations il est sanctionné
mais il faut qu'il en soit même pour les
entreprises
très bien Madame la rapporteur vous
souhaitiez intervenir avant que nous
passions vote oui merci
très bien il y a de la place ici
Monsieur si ça vous dérange pas d'être à
côté de mes collègues Renaissance là il
y a deux places monsieur le député
madame la rapporteur vous avez
ça ne me dérange absolument pas je suis
très républicaine aucun problème
monsieur le député
installez-vous discrètement madame la
rapporteur va prendre la parole madame
cela rapporteur à la parole s'il vous
plaît merci madame la Présidente je
voulais s'il vous plaît je voulais
essayer de répondre à Madame Tallier
polluant sur la part des produits de
cotisations des entreprises puisque elle
avait elle a posé la question donc en
2019 c'est 257 milliards d'euros en 2023
292 c'est à dire une augmentation de 35
milliards d'euros dont 6 milliards pour
la branche d'Assurance Maladie 20
milliards pour la branche assurance
vieillesse
merci bien Madame la rapporteur donc je
vais
soumettre aux voix donc cette liasse
d'amendement alors je passe déjà au 38
57 alors ils ont tous reçu un avis
défavorable de Madame la rapporteur
général très bien alors je vous soumets
le 38 57 qui est pour
seul vote bien sûr les membres de la
commission
très bien non mais chers collègues je
préfère quand même le rappeler voilà
alors
qui est contre
il est rejeté même avis même votre le 38
56 même avis même vote le 38,5 alors je
mets en voix le 38 55 et pour
qui est pour
qui est contre donc c'est bien même à
vie même vote
alors
alors on n'est pas dans une cour de
récré là ok alors le 38 54 qui est pour
qui est contre
le 38 45 même avis même votes même avis
même vote le 38 53 même avis même vote
qui est pour non mais attendez c'est la
même chose
pour non mais ne me dites pas non moi je
vois bien d'ici que c'est le même nom
attendez il ne dites pas
alors non non mais là vous faites mumuse
avec moi alors qui est pour
c'est vraiment désolé pour qui est
contre il est bien rejeté le 38 52 qui
est pour qui contre il est rejeté le 38
51 pour contre rejeter 38,50 pour contre
rejeter 38 49 pour contre rejeter alors
sur les amendements identiques je les
soumets les trois les deux il y en a
pardon 47 89 38 48 quai pour
contre rejeter le 38 47 qui est pour
contre rejeté 38 46 pour contre rejeter
38 43 pour contre rejeter 38 44 pour
contre rejeter 38 58 pour contre rejeter
38 39 pour contre rejeter 38-42 pour
contre rejeter 38 41 pour contre rejeter
31-50 pour contre rejeter amendement
identique j'en ai trois sur le 4 sur le
10% alors je les rappelle 38 856 30 13
32 40 et 63 55 pour
contre tous rejetés alors pareil
amendement
identique j'en ai trois alors pour
contre rejeter amendement
identique sur le 8 % qui est pour contre
rejeter amendement identique sur les 7%
pour contre rejeter amendement identique
6% pour contre rejeter amendement à au
moins égal à 5% qui est pour
contre rejeter amendement identique sur
le taux de 5% qui est pour contre tous
rejetés amendement identique sur le taux
de 4% pour contre rejeter amendement
identique sur le 3 % pour contre rejeter
amendement identique 2% pour contre
rejeter et enfin amendement au moins
égal à 1% pour
contre
rejeter je vous remercie mes chers
collègues
allez on y va alors Monsieur Bazin avec
le 48 35 oui merci madame la Présidente
c'est un moment vous propose d'adapter
la rédaction de la Linéa 10 ainsi la
pénalité est prononcée dans des
conditions prévues par décret en Conseil
d'État son menton son montant tient
compte des motifs de mes connaissances
d'obligation de publication pourquoi je
vous propose ça c'est qu'on voit bien
aujourd'hui dans la rédaction telle
qu'elle est prévue c'est que c'est très
flou d'ailleurs il y a pas de définition
juridique des seniors il y a pas de
précision d'ailleurs on peut même se
demander vu les différences de
situations entre secteur d'activité
entre entreprises est-ce qu'on va
sérieusement envisager d'exiger d'une
startup de codage informatique d'avoir
le même taux de salarié seniors ou la
même politique de formation à leur égard
qu'une grande entreprise de service dans
un secteur plus traditionnel de de
l'économie moi il me semble que que
l'approche qui qui est traduite par la
rédaction actuelle ne sont pas adaptées
à la réalité des entreprises et des
secteurs et à l'enjeu majeur qui est
celui de l'emploi des seniors il faut
qu'on puisse avoir quelque chose de
beaucoup plus adapté qu'il s'agisse de
la formation des parcours de d'emploi de
reconversion et d'incitation à
l'embauche
très bien monsieur le député madame la
rapporteur oui merci merci madame la
Présidente on est dans le concret mais
je suis pas d'accord avec vous parce que
si vous les retirer la modulation sur
les forces ça veut dire qu'une
entreprise qui aurait fait un effort
vous allez lui augmenter sa pénalité
donc je pense qu'il y a vraiment
l'importance de garder les deux critères
de modulation soit parce qu'il a des
bonnes raisons d'entreprise a des bonnes
raisons de pas le faire comme par
exemple un plan social en cours mais
effectivement il faut aussi regarder
parce que si aucun effort est fait sur
l'emploi des seniors il faut en tenir
compte
très bien
oui ce qui m'a interpellé en fait dans
la manière de prévoir cette index c'est
qu'en fait c'est soumis une appréciation
qualitative de l'administration si on
calque par rapport à l'index égalité
homme-femme il y a une obligation légale
en matière d'égalité femme homme et il y
a un respect j'allais dire
quantitative qui objectivable la
distinction et objectivable sur l'index
senior en l'état sans précision je vous
dois vous avouer
sans ces précisions avec le flou qui
demeure et compris sur la définition que
que cette appréciation laissée à
l'administration peut apparaître
inquiétante et qui que ce la mériterait
j'ai bien compris qu'on allait attendre
les négociations pour ensuite codifier
mais en l'état moi je trouve que cette
appréciation laissée à l'administration
me convient pas et et on peut pas le
calquer par rapport à l'index qui est
beaucoup plus objectivable il faut qu'on
équilibre les choses et qu'on a juste à
mon avis cette rédaction très bien
Madame la rapporteur
parce qu'en fait c'est quand même prévu
par décret en Conseil d'État donc ce qui
nécessite un socle juridique bien
costaud donc c'est un avis défavorable
très bien donc alors mes chers collègues
il nous reste quelques minutes encore
séance il y a Monsieur cloué qui
souhaite intervenir et puis après je
suspends pour qu'on nous puissions tous
aller voter très bien donc monsieur
Clouet vous allez être concis toujours
madame la Présidente mais c'est vrai
mais mais d'abord juste pour pour
démarrer d'abord je souhaiterais
évidemment féliciter mesdames leur
rapporteur et la présidente pour les
15000 manifestants dans chacune de vos
deux circonscriptions respectives
aujourd'hui et je vous en félicite après
sur le fond de l'amendement je pense que
Monsieur Bazin pose une question qui est
importante c'est celle de l'objectif
qu'on assigne à cet outil alors si si je
saisis bien ce que vous voulez faire en
l'occurrence c'est retirer de la
pénalité en tout cas du champ de la
pénalité déjà très faible l'effort qui
serait constaté c'est à dire un faire
une marque d'intention c'est ça que vous
voulez retirer monsieur Bazin du
dispositif tel qu'il existe en tout cas
c'est comme ça que je l'ai compris mais
je vous pose la question parce que en
conséquence si on retire effectivement
quand vous le proposez une partie du
texte à savoir
le fait d'avoir pardon je cite les
efforts constatés si on retire les
efforts constatés ça veut quand même
dire que il suffira de publier un index
que personne ou peu de monde va lire
faute d'énergie de temps et de structure
adaptée pour procéder à son évaluation
avec des indicateurs qui eux-mêmes sont
abandonnés la discrétion extrêmement
forte des administrations et des
entreprises pour continuer son petit
bonhomme de chemin de manière assez
indifférente à la politique d'emploi
effectivement menée parmi les seniors et
dès lors monsieur le Bazin enfin dans
votre amendement je dis monsieur Bazin
mais
j'imagine que vous le portez avec
d'autres personnes vous vous étonnez de
l'aspect qualitatif alors
cet étonnement m'étonne parce que le
droit en tant que tel est toujours un
procédure un processus qualitatif
c'est-à-dire il faut toujours évaluer
des choses par exemple l'index lui-même
dont on parle il y a évidemment une
nuance qualitative entre ce qui serait
un index il n'en serait pas entre le
fait de le diffuser ou le fait de pas le
diffuser si un employeur crée un index
mais le garde pour lui il a
effectivement construit une index mais
la non diffusion conduirait à le
considérer comme ne l'ayant pas produit
bref il y a toujours une dimension
qualitative et c'est la même chose pour
l'index égalité femme homme il y a
toujours un objectif il y a toujours une
attention qui est recherché du côté
employeur pour évaluer les pratiques sur
le fait en revanche qui est pas de
définition des seniors c'est vrai mais
ça vous savez bien que nous sommes un
peu victimes puisque nous avons proposé
des amendements vous aussi pour mieux
qualifier ce qu'est un travailleur ou
une travailleuse senior ils ont pas été
acceptés mais il me semble que
l'objectif qu'on doit avoir tout est
tous ensemble c'est plutôt de préciser
ce qui est un senior pour rendre
applicable le peu qu'il y a
d'intéressant dans un index plutôt que
d'y renoncer et de détricoter l'outil
lui-même en revanche vous avez également
raison sur un point c'est les effets
sectoriels et il est clair que se pose
la question des vœux d'emploi des
seniors on n'est pas obligé d'égaliser
de manière interceptable gentillesse et
de ma bonté comme toujours
alors non c'est très rare maintenant
présidente mais c'est parce que le
moment est très intéressant mais en tout
cas nous votre rencontre très bien merci
monsieur le député allez je vais mettre
au voie c'est à Monsieur bazar
redemander la parole
il a déjà parlé avant
donc c'est très bon
alors je mets aux voix c'est un
abonnement qui a reçu un avis donc
défavorable de Madame la rapporteur qui
est pour qui est contre il est rejeté je
vous remercie et bien nous allons tous
toutes et tous allez voter
c'est bien voilà nous a essayé c'est bon
donc nous allons reprendre avec
l'amendement donc
31-56 et donc
oui monsieur jumelle
bon c'est un amendement du groupe Geder
mais largement partagé par les personnes
qui sont à côté de moi au cœur de
l'hémicier
bon d'abord je voulais vous dire que
j'ai pris un bar d'énergie considérable
aujourd'hui à Dieppe dans une belle
manif il y avait 8000 personnes c'est
vraiment ressourçant parce que ça donne
du sens de revenir ici quand on a fait
une manif comme ça donc je voulais
commencer par cela et dans cette manif
j'ai rencontré un gars qui s'appelle
Sylvain volta il a il a cotisé 42 42 ans
il a été dans les cours de marées je
passais quelque chose pour les parts
égaux les cours de marée mais c'est là
que c'est l'axe négocie et que ce
traite le poisson et puis désormais il
est agent de proximité chez un meilleur
social il est d'une certaine manière
non pas
proxénète comme dit le collègue qui
m'entoure mais agent de proximité qui
prend soin des habitants
du logement social et après donc
168 trimestres de cotisation il va avoir
une retraite de 1030 euros 53 je voulais
vous dire ça parce que c'est pour eux
aussi que nous sommes là aujourd'hui et
c'est avec cette force-là que nous
venons dans l'hémicycle alors
l'amendement qu'on vous présente vise à
vous permettre de remettre un peu de
paritarisme dans la gestion de la
question des retraites vous qui avez
estatisé la gestion de l'assurance
maladie et vous qui rêvez au bout du
compte pour délibéré ça paraît peut-être
paradoxal de tout étatisé nous proposons
donc absolument de solliciter l'accord
des organisations syndicales et
patronales pour mettre en place l'index
qui nous occupe depuis quelques heures
voilà le sens de l'amendement présenté
merci monsieur le député madame la
rapporteur votre avis pour cet
amendement
je vous donne le micro
merci madame la Présidente on a beaucoup
débattu sur cet article est en précisant
que les organisations syndicales seront
fortement associées à la mise en place
de l'index notamment dans la définition
des critères donc je donne un avis
défavorable
très bien Madame nosion
oui monsieur
je oui je voudrais réagir à cet
amendement mais d'abord faire une
parenthèse puisque tout à l'heure on a
eu droit à nouveau à cette petite
musique sur le plein emploi dans
certains départements
qui seraient atteint
qui voudrait dire que ce qu'on raconte
c'est n'importe quoi bien je voudrais
citer
des députés macronistes ou plutôt je
devrais dire d'anciens députés
macronistes c'est dur on rame il y a une
vingtaine ou une trentaine de postes par
an qui peuvent correspondre à leur
profil quand vous avez une centaine de
personnes au CV très proche qui cherche
forcément ça fait trop de candidats et
bien voilà vos collègues macronistes vos
anciens collègues voteront sûrement
nupette maintenant qui se sont rendus
compte que ce que nous racontions sur
votre politique en matière de travail
était juste on comprend mieux que plus
personne ne vous croit vous avez saccagé
le code du travail vous avez continué en
saccageant le système d'attribution des
indemnités chômage et vous vous attaquez
maintenant au retraite j'en profite pour
saluer les mobilisations dans le pays
plus de 500000 personnes à Paris plus de
30000 plus de 30000 personnes chez moi à
Montpellier combien dans le pays
2,8 millions on me dit à ma droite
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît alors je
crois que nous pouvons bien Madame la
député si vous le voulez bien j'y viens
j'y viens mais je crois que justement
nous pouvons accorder ce pas
d'ailleurs les les modalités
d'applications proposées notamment en
consultant les organisations syndicales
et patronales parce que cela permettra
une plus grande justice
très bien monsieur Benz vous avez la
parole
oui merci madame la Présidente
permettez-moi juste une minute de
revenir sur ce qui s'est passé avant la
suspension de notre commission parce que
quand même on a un vrai problème on
tourne en rond depuis maintenant plus de
5 heures
sur l'article 2 je trouve que de la part
de laupes ce n'est franchement pas
sérieux je propose qu'on arrête plutôt
qui les arrête l'obstruction
parlementaire puisque ça a été avoué par
Madame Rousseau tout à l'heure elle l'a
avoué cette obstruction elle risque elle
risque de que nous ne puisse pas que
l'on puisse pas s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît non mais pas de
provocation s'il vous plaît et Manon de
la nups pour le coup j'ai entendu
jusqu'ici retourne à la Bouvette là ça
ne va pas et ça ne passe pas je suis
désolé c'est quoi ça
quand on a le
c'est honteux même si honteux de dire ça
c'est honteux quelle image vous renvoyez
devant les Français la représentation
nationale c'est une honte c'est une
honte
très bien
c'est une honte c'est une honte seul
monsieur le député à la parole monsieur
Benz à la parole merci et on l'écoute
même si on n'est pas d'accord avec ces
idées on écoute c'est la moindre des
choses ça s'appelle du respect et avoir
un minimum d'éducation
[Musique]
merci merci
vous avez la parole vous n'avez pas la
parole madame la députée monsieur Benz
vous avez la parole je vous remercie
sincèrement madame la Présidente pour
cette mise au point ce que nous crions
sur le fond sur le fond ce que nous
crayons c'est que nous n'ayons pas le
temps de traiter et de débattre de
l'article 7 qui est le cœur nucléaire
comme notre collègue la rabais tout à
l'heure
arrêtons la récupération politique
évoquer les manifestations en commission
ou en hémicycle comme nous comme nous
comme le rassemblement national 70% des
Français sont effectivement opposés à
cette réforme et nous sommes ici pour
nous y opposer mais vous n'avez pas le
monopole de ces manifestations chers
collègues de la nupesse 70% des Français
s'opposent à cette réforme que nous
considérons comme injuste mais il me
semble que Jean-Luc Mélenchon n'a pas
fait 70% des voix à l'élection
présidentielle il était même pas au
second tour alors conclusion je vous
propose que vous arrêtiez la
récupération politique que l'on arrête
la construction parlementaire et que
l'on aille au plus vite à l'article 4
qui est le cœur de débat c'est là où les
Français nous attendent je vous remercie
merci madame la Présidente
moi aussi je voulais apporter un
témoignage moi j'ai lancé un appel à
témoignage en demandant aux gens et vous
qu'est-ce que vous voudriez faire à 60
ans pour montrer qu'il y a plein
d'autres choses à faire que de continuer
à travailler éternellement et Valérie
qui a 42 ans m'a écrit d'Annonay a donné
vous savez c'est la ville dont Olivier
du soft a été maire pendant une
décennies et elle m'a écrit je voudrais
me former à nouvelle connaissance
m'engager voyager préserver ma santé en
faisant du sport et elle a ajouté que à
Annonay aujourd'hui il y avait 8700
personnes dans la rue soit le double du
jeudi 19 janvier voilà une mobilisation
historique sur les terres même du
ministre
très bien monsieur Bazin
non vous n'aviez pas demandé la parole
monsieur Bazin si
s'il vous plaît madame la Présidente je
pense qu'il est important
c'est quand même un sujet qui préoccupe
les Français et je crois que ça ça nous
rassemble tous à la fois ceux qui sont
déjà en retraite ceux qui seront ceux
qui travaillent c'est une réforme qui
mérite qu'on puisse débattre de manière
très posée c'est un sujet sérieux et
donc je pense que il faut qu'on retrouve
des conditions d'échange de débat de
manière à ce qu'on débattre sur le fond
et et les petites phrases et
provocations ne contribuent pas à cela
je crois que c'est très important qu'on
puisse revenir sur les ensembles de
l'articles on a du mal à avancer mais je
crois que les différents articles qui se
succèdent vont permettre de faire valoir
les différentes positions mais mais
vraiment soyons à la hauteur aussi du de
ces enjeux très bien monsieur Vigier
non vous l'avez pas demandé très bien
aucun problème alors là j'ai deux
demandes madame Parmentier ou madame
Vidal madame Vidal très bien
merci madame la Présidente à mon tour je
voudrais revenir sur ce qui s'est passé
ce qui se passe globalement dans cette
commission depuis plusieurs heures
nous savions que vous faisiez de
l'obstruction maintenant ça a été
clairement annoncé par ma collègue nupes
nous savons aussi que vous ne voulez pas
de cette réforme donc vous ne voulez pas
préserver le système de retraite par
répartition auquel les Français sont
très attachés vous ne voulez pas
garantir la retraite des Français vous
ne voulez pas augmenter la retraite
minimale de 100 euros vous ne voulez pas
augmenter les trimestres pour les congés
maternité vous ne voulez pas prendre en
compte des trimestres valoriser les
trimestres pour les proches aidants de
fait vous cautionnez des déficits vous
acceptez d'inscrire 150 milliards de
dettes pour les générations futures tout
cela au nom de votre idée au logis et
vous faites le choix
d'organiser un non débat vous ne voulez
que le chaos alors que les Français nous
regardent alors que les Français
attendent de nous un débat digne riche
et constructif sur une réforme qui
concerne et qui concernera tous les
Français dans leur quotidien ici ce
n'est nous sommes dans une cour de
récréation ici c'est la guerre des
boutons et la bataille des billes
franchement les Français méritent
beaucoup mieux que cela très bien
monsieur jumelles
non mais moi je enfin vous ne voulez pas
vous ne voulez pas vous ne voulez pas
entendre que que la majorité des
Français est opposée à votre mauvaise
réforme vous ne voulez pas entendre qu'à
la faveur de votre projet nous allons
détériorer la prise en charge des femmes
dans leur accès au droit à la retraite
vous ne voulez pas entendre que votre
index c'est de la Seigneur et c'est de
la poudre de perlimpinpin qui n'apporte
aucune réponse au taux de chômage des
seniors alors il employabilité et ou
alors difficulté d'accéder notamment à
l'emploi dans les zones les plus tendues
en matière de chômage vous ne voulez pas
entendre des amendements qui ne sont pas
des amendements d'obstruction
aucun aucun
des Allemands je vous mets au défi de
trouver un seul amendement de friction
porté porté par le groupe porté par le
groupe GDR celui-ci vise celui-ci vise à
faire en sorte que nous sollicitions
l'accord des organisations syndicales et
patronales pour coélaborer les critères
liés à l'index est-ce que c'est un
amendement de friction aucun d'entre
vous n'a répondu à cette question et
donc vous êtes sourd vous êtes dans
l'extrême brillante solitude du pouvoir
dans l'extrême brillant de solitude du
pouvoir et vous savez à force de vouloir
se rassembler soi-même on finit par être
vraiment seul et donc c'est ce que nous
pronostiquons comme aboutissement à
cette mauvaise réforme dont nous
demandons dont nous demandons en
l'assumant le retrait le retrait
simplement le retrait entièrement le
retrait complètement donc voilà on va on
va multiplier les occasions de vous le
dire
très bien
monsieur Cyril Isaac Sibille
merci madame la Présidente nous parlons
d'un taux de pénibilité pour les
entreprises n'ayant pas plus index
Seigneur en faveur des emplois des
travailleurs au-dessus de 55 ans
là qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que nous
venons de faire nous avons examiné tout
à l'heure des dizaines d'amendements que
députés de la vitesse avaient posées
hier nous avons entendu les députés du
peste nous expliquer que ça index ne
servirait à rien serait un rideau de
fumée une fumisterie hypocrite voire une
salade décorative
hier nous avons entendu nous expliquer
que ces données étaient déjà publiques
en nous donnant le nom des entreprises
aujourd'hui nous venons d'écouter une
hauteur de ses amendements qui vient
nous expliquer que voter ses propres
amendements seraient une insulte et une
indécence
mesdames et messieurs les députés de la
mupestres je vous demande de respecter
nos débats le travail parlementaire de
l'Assemblée dont vous êtes élu et ne
peut pas les tourner au ridicule
mesdames et messieurs les députés nous
vous demandons un minimum de
responsabilité
jumelles s'il vous plaît
monsieur le député vous avez fini
monsieur Cyril liseaccibil merci très
bien donc je mets aux voix cet
amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de Madame la rapporteur qui
est pour
qui contre il est rejeté amendement
suivant est-il défendu
non oui
non non
ensuite monsieur Petavy
pour le 6662
[Musique]
alors la Linéa 10 de l'article 2 prévoit
que le montant de la pénalité financière
tienne compte des efforts constatés dans
l'entreprise en matière d'emploi des
seniors ainsi que des motifs de
méconnaissance d'obligation de
publication nous devons le dire nous
avons déjà nullement confiance en cette
index qui ressemble beaucoup à la
dernière baguette magique en date du
gouvernement pour répondre à des enjeux
sociaux qui sont pourtant réels et
concernent des millions de Françaises et
Français nous sommes d'autant plus
méfiants envers cette disposition de la
Linéa 10 qui semble ouvrir la voie à
tous les arbitraires et les largesses
pour donner des excuses aux entreprises
qui ne respectent pas leur obligation
envers les seniors nous demandons donc
la suppression de cette disposition car
nous estimons qu'avec 160 milliards
d'euros d'exonération de cotisations les
entreprises ont bénéficié de
suffisamment de largesse
très bien Madame la rapporteur
c'est un avis défavorable je vous donne
juste un exemple d'une entreprise qui
serait en plan de sauvegarde de l'emploi
on imagine bien qu'elle ne va pas
publier son son index donc avis
défavorable très bien monsieur léoman
oui merci madame la Présidente je suis
désolé c'est très difficile de
travailler dans ces conditions là parce
que on a vraiment beaucoup de monde qui
est là et donc c'est un peu compliqué ne
serait-ce que de se saisir d'un micro je
pense qu'il serait temps de d'avoir une
salle plus grande maintenant sur le fond
de cet amendement c'est quand même
incroyable parce que chaque fois qu'on
propose des choses qui vont dans le sens
d'une disons d'une limitation de des
largets s'accorder aux entreprises on a
des avis défavorables là c'est quand
même un petit amendement entre
guillemets ça permet de sensiblement
améliorer les choses ben non avis
défavorable et à chaque fois qu'on a
proposé des choses sur le sujet avis
défavorable alors que même alors même
pardon que tout le monde convient
désormais que c'est index senior ne sert
à peu près à rien d'autant plus que il
ne sanctionne pas parce que il faut bien
qu'on comprenne il sanctionne pas le
fait de pas embaucher à cette senior il
sanctionne le fait de ne pas rendre
public les chiffres d'emploi des seniors
c'est quand même c'est quand même un
truc qui est à peu près nul quoi c'est
totalement lamentable maintenant
pourquoi on passe du temps dessus il
faut en parler un petit peu on passe du
temps dessus parce qu'au tout début de
l'examen de l'article 2 nous avions
déposé des amendements de suppression
parce qu'on considérait que ça servait
rigoureusement à rien et que le
rassemblement national qui était sans
doute un peu perdu à ce moment-là un peu
à la ramasse comme d'habitude n'a pas vu
n'a pas su quoi voter et donc au lieu de
voter la suppression de cet article 2
qui aurait permis d'avancer et bien ils
ont refusé maintenant je constate
quelque chose le rassemblement national
nous dit vite vite allons à l'article 7
votons l'article 7 avançons finalement
vous êtes comme les macronistes vous
voulez allez vite vous voulez avancer
vous voulez aller sur cet article 7
peut-être pour faire passer la retraite
à 64 ans finalement peut-être que vous
êtes d'accord c'était dans le programme
de Zemmour après tout un petit pas de
plus et vous y êtes presque chez Zemmour
alors voilà vous êtes sans doute en
train de vouloir avancer la retraite à
64 ans vous êtes contre c'est la 60 la
rapporteur va vous répondre
dans la rue
et qu'on veut pouvoir améliorer ce texte
on veut l'enrichir donc avançons pour
travailler c'est à dire pas sur des
amendements d'obstruction très bien
Madame ibora
s'il vous plaît
on écoute madame Bora oui vous dites que
les enfermé dans notre dans le pouvoir
dans notre pouvoir mais je crois que
vous vous êtes enfermé dans votre
idéologie vous n'en sortez pas et vos
propositions tournent autour de cette
idéologie et donc vous êtes en plus très
agité comme d'habitude
provocateur et agressif est-ce que alors
que vous devriez être alors ce que vous
tais-toi alors que vous devriez être au
contraire détendu heureux de voir le
nombre de manifestants est-ce que vous
êtes déçu du nombre de manifestants on
peut se poser la question quand même
franchement
très bien Madame Rousseau
en fait
on écoute madame Rousseau là moi
j'entends que vous vouliez être
constructif que vous vouliez
co-construire etc sauf que depuis le
début en fait aucun de nos amendements
n'ont été acceptés et au-delà de au-delà
de la de du détail de chacun il y en
avait qui était largement recevable et
qui aurait pu mettre un tout petit peu
de contraintes sur les entreprises et en
fait vous jouez un jeu qui est un jeu
délétère qui est de dire rien n'est
négociable dans notre texte et 64 ans ou
rien aucun des amendements ne passera
donc la brutalité dont vous faites
preuve et bien voilà nous vous la
renvoyons en essayant par tous les
moyens par tous les moyens d'obtenir au
moins le mode le mode d'un amendement
très bien très bien
monsieur de la porte
au calme alors que je pense que nous
avons fait preuve de mesure depuis le
début de ces travaux
je suis particulièrement outré parce que
je considère finalement que quand vous
dites que nous campons sur notre
idéologie alors qu'on parle juste ici
d'essayer de faire en sorte l'index
senior que vous proposez puisse
appliquer très concrètement avec des
propositions pour le renforcer même à la
migoura c'est pas de l'idéologie ça on
va dans le sens de ce que propose le
gouvernement dont on critique par
ailleurs
l'aveuglement et l'idéologie puisque
cette réforme elle n'a aucun fondement
donc si je peux me permettre de vous
répondre oui nous on est là on est
connecté en effet avec des manifestants
qui nous soutiennent et nous supportent
et c'est vrai qu'on en est heureux et
vous avez raison de le souligner on en
est extrêmement heureux mais on est
aussi très malheureux de voir que ce
texte n'assume même pas les rares
petites ambitions qui décident d'avancer
et c'est pour ça qu'on se bat
aujourd'hui aussi c'est pour essayer
d'obtenir des avancées dans le texte en
plus des avancées qu'il y a dans la rue
et en espérant qu'à un moment vous
donnerez écouter les oppositions très
donc je mets aux voix c'est amendement
qui a reçu un avis défavorable de Madame
la rapporteur général qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté amendement
suivant monsieur d'arriville monsieur
monsieur Daredevil vous avez la parole
pour le 31 54
merci madame la Présidente
oui donc cette amendement visa à
préciser encore une fois ce dispositif
je voudrais simplement rappeler que nous
souhaitons essayer donner une sorte
d'efficacité quand même à la disposition
qui qui a été proposée en essayant de
faire en sorte que ça soit accompagné
d'objectifs et puis qui est une
évaluation de ces objectifs et que tout
ça puisse donner lieu quand même à une
validation et éventuellement à des
sanctions si c'est nécessaire donc voilà
la proposition que nous avons faite
s'inscrit dans dans une logique de
rendre vraiment le mécanisme opérant et
de pas en rester à une sorte d'affichage
bon voilà donc j'espère je remercie
madame la rapporteur qui qui répond à
tous nos amendements depuis depuis hier
je sais que c'est un travail fastidieux
et voilà bon madame la Première ministre
a effectivement dit que l'article 7
n'était pas négociable ce qui à mon avis
pose un problème majeur puisque c'est
l'article central de votre projet de loi
et que donc ça fait quand même des
choses qui qui crispent la situation
mais cela étant dit voilà du coup on
discute au moins du reste même si ça ne
suffira pas voilà donc en tout cas ici
là il y a un dispositif précis qui est
sans doute discutable madame la
rapporteur mais que nous avons mis sur
la table pour essayer de faire en sorte
qu'une proposition puisqu’un même
émerger de nos débats qui est un effet
sur l'emploi des ce qu'on appelle ceux
que on appelle peut-être un proprement
les seniors très bien Madame la
rapporteur votre avis merci monsieur une
ville pour votre amendement on n'a pas
adopté les critères chiffrés donc on
pourra pas avoir des objectifs chiffrés
donc c'est une raison pour laquelle on
est défavorable enfin je suis
défavorable à cet amendement très bien
monsieur le gars oui bah justement c'est
bien ça le problème mais madame la
rapporteur vous avez dit à l'instant
lors de la de l'amendement précédent
quelque chose qui qui pose un grave
problème tout de même vous nous accuser
de faire de l'obstruction mais prenons
l'amendement dont on est en train de
discuter là dont on est en train de
parler c'est tout le monde convient ici
qui a un problème très important
concernant l'emploi des seniors tout le
monde sait qu'à 61 ans plus de la moitié
des seniors se retrouvent dans une
situation ils sont sans emploi on vous
propose là une mesure c'est parfaitement
vrai au contraire mais vous avez le
droit de l'ignorer et de ne pas voir la
réalité c'est d'ailleurs votre marque de
fabrique mais mais on vous propose là
une mesure pour permettre pour faciliter
ou améliorer la situation en emploi et
l'embauche des salariés âgés de 50 ans
et plus vous ne répondez une fois de
plus par une fin de non-recevoir c'est
systématique sur toutes les questions et
surtout les âmes que nous vous avons
posé surtout les amendements que nous
avons défendus écoutez à un moment donné
il va y avoir un problème aujourd'hui il
y avait près de 3 millions de personnes
dans les rues il serait temps d'entendre
parce qu'à force de gouverner
il y a être près de 3 millions de
personnes dans les rues absolument près
de 3 millions de personnes vous avez
réussi vous avez réussi un exploit ce le
président de la République depuis 2017
ses vertus à faire des organisations
syndicales de simples accompagnants de
ces mesures elles sont aujourd'hui
toutes unis contre votre projet de
réforme des retraites et bilan des
courses il y a près de 3 millions de
personnes dans les rues alors il serait
temps d'entendre parce qu'à force de
gouverner contre le pays et bien le
pouvoir risque d'avoir de graves
difficultés et je pense que ce qui est
en train de commencer donc entendez
je sais que je prends des risques en
m'exprimant ici là je mais je vais quand
même le quand même le faire
vous avez là la nouvelle illustration
d'un amendement solide dans travailler
dans un amendement propositionnel qui
vise à conditionner l'efficacité de
l'index à l'établissement de sanction si
les objectifs ne sont pas atteints hier
le débat que nous avons eu qui était
très utile a permis de démontrer que
votre index n'a menait rien de nouveau
sous le soleil dans les boîtes de plus
de 300 salariés par rapport au bilan
social qui existe déjà les bilans
sociaux nous permettent d'ores et déjà
d'avoir une vision du nombre de seniors
employés y compris des formations
mobilisées au sein de l'entreprise et la
manière dont sur plusieurs années ce
sujet là est traité donc votre index
n'amène rien de nouveau sur les bilans
sociaux la seule intérêt que pourrait
avoir votre index s'il voulait être
utile
à la lutte contre le taux de chômage des
seigneurs ce serait qu'il soit assorti
de sanctions de sanction c'est
l'objet de l'excellent amendement de mon
collègue d'arrivée alors après tout ça
vous pouvez plus parler d'obstruction
vous êtes vous êtes contraint de
reconnaître que on a l'ultex on dit
qu'il est pourri on a raison de le dire
mais en même temps on vise à le rendre
un petit peu moins pourri alors aux
frontières aux marges sur la question
des seigneurs notamment c'est le sens de
l'amendement qui est proposé et dont
nous espérons qu'il va prospérer très
bien Monsieur Marc Ferracci
oui merci madame la Présidente bon juste
un élément très factuel pour
pourtant le coup à un chiffre que
j'entends depuis des jours des semaines
l'idée selon laquelle 50% des personnes
seraient au chômage ou en inactivité au
moment de la retraite
je vous donne je vous donne simplement
ce qui figure dans les dans les rapports
du corps ce sont des chiffres qui sont
issus des enquêtes emploi de l'Insee à
62 ans à 62 ans
c'est tout le temps je vais même prendre
61 ans parce que c'est c'est l'âge qui a
été évoqué tout à l'heure le total des
personnes qui ne sont ni en emploi ni à
la retraite ou en pré-retraite c'est
27%. 25% des gens sont à la retraite on
pourrait retraite et tout le reste vient
être en emploi à 62 ans qui est quand
même l'âge auquel on peut s'intéresser
seul 16% des gens de 6 ne sont ni en
emploi ni à la retraite ça veut dire
concrètement que c'est assez 16% et
uniquement à ces 16% qu'il faut que nous
nous intéressions collectivement 16% ça
n'est pas 50%. donc il faut arrêter les
fake news il faut arrêter de donner des
chiffres faux il faut arrêter
de mettre dans le débat non non non les
gens qui sont arrêtés pour incapacité et
des gens qui sont arrêtés pour
incapacité encore une fois son
comptabilisés ici dans les inactifs donc
il y a vraiment aucune difficulté les
gens qui ne sont vraiment vraiment
on risque et bien ne sont pas 50% comme
vous le dites
très bien merci monsieur le député
monsieur Delaporte
madame Rousseau
très bien monsieur Vigier oui merci
madame la Présidente
je crois que depuis le début de
l'après-midi sur cette affaire du taux
des emplois des seniors et la volonté je
l'ai dit il y a eu beaucoup de calme
je pense que chacun des groupes
politiques ici déplore le fait que tout
l'emplacement soit trop faible dans ce
pays et c'est un GSU humain et nous
avons fait des propositions je voudrais
simplement dire aux collègues de la
nupesse
que qu'elle n'a pas été mon émotion de
voir que lorsque nous avons proposé tout
à l'heure
un système de bonus malus dans les
entreprises pour voir celles qui étaient
justement en capacité de plus employés
des seniors et celle qui ne le faisaient
pas à l'image peut terminer s'il vous
plaît je vais bien tout mais moi je vous
ai écouté donc vous me laissez terminer
d'accord ça sera très bien comme ça et
donc j'ai été surpris de voir qu'avec ce
système virtueux parce qu'en plus il
s'équilibre entre les bonus et le malus
à l'image c'est ce qu'ils ont fait pour
les CDD j'ai vu que vous n'étiez pas
présent vous n'allez pas voté vous avez
même pas levé la main et on demandera le
procès-verbal ne me le faites pas comme
ça pas ça ne marchera pas en revanche
vos amis socialistes eux l'ont voté donc
vous voyez malheureusement là je vais
vous prendre les mains dans le pot de
confiture uniquement dans le blocage
lorsqu'il y a un acte de responsabilité
à portée vous ne le portez pas
très bien Madame la rapporteur vous
souhaitiez dire un mot ou pas non très
bien je mets aux voix cet amendement ah
pardon monsieur ménager
merci merci Madame présidente bon on se
rend tous compte qu'on est en train de
s'enliser voire pire on est en train de
totalement sans bourber sur cette sur
cette index qui en plus va sûrement être
retoqué au moment du passage devant le
Conseil constitutionnel alors moi j'ai
une solution je pense qu'il va pouvoir
rassembler tout le monde parce que nous
rassemblement national avec Marine Le
Pen on veut rassembler face à un
gouvernement qui cherche à diviser et
donc nous nous proposons notamment à la
nupes dans quelques jours nous aurons
une motion référendaire vous aurez la
possibilité de voter et donner la
possibilité aux Français de s'exprimer
sur ce projet et je vous dis ça peut
rassembler puisqu'en fait le modem
j'écoutais mon mon collègue de la région
Centre Val de Loire Philippe Vigier à
l'instant le modem est Monsieur Bayrou
disait le 25 janvier que l'idée que
devant les extrêmes difficultés d'une
réforme des traits des retraites les
tranchées par un référendum et la
meilleure solution aujourd'hui on vous
propose de sortir par le haut ça
permettrait en fait à la fois la
majorité de sortir par le haut et de
montrer pour une fois après 50 mépris
après 5 ans d'absence d'empathie
d'écouter le nous vous proposons de
sortir la tête haute en donnant la voix
aux Français nous nous croyons à
l'intelligence des Français nous nous
croyons à ce que les Français puissent
s'exprimer directement sur ce projet
puisse voir à quel point il est injuste
à quel point il est inutile et c'est la
raison pour laquelle mesdames et
messieurs damupes mesdames et messieurs
notamment du modèle nous verrons si vous
changez encore une fois de ligne nous
verrons si vous êtes en cohérence nous
verrons si vous croyez aux Français vous
croyez au peuple vous croyez à la
souveraineté populaire en votant lundi
la mention référendaire portée par le
rassemblement national
très bien donc sur ce je mets aux voix
donc cet amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable qui est pour qui est contre
il est rejeté amendement suivant
monsieur ménager
madame
très bien Madame leva allez-y alors
c'est un moment vice à rendre plus
objectif les éléments retenus dans le
cadre des sanctions prévues pour cet
article 2 du point de vue de la
prévisibilité et de la sécurité
juridique la formulation retenue par le
texte n'est pas satisfaisante les termes
sont imprécis et leurs contours sont
flous en effet loin de définir
clairement les critères à respecter sous
peine de sauveur infligés une sanction
administrative le texte se borne à
prévoir que le montant de la pénalité
tient compte des efforts constatés dans
l'entreprise en matière d'emploi des
seigneurs
très bien Madame la rapporteur
par définition le montant de la sanction
se fondra sur des éléments objectifs
pris en compte par l'autorité
administrative et précisé par décret au
Conseil d'État c'est donc un avis
défavorable merci Madame la rapporteur
général madame panot
merci à madame la Présidente alors à
l'instant on a fait un cours d'éducation
et de politesse à ma camarade Farina
Amrani moi je voudrais dire que je
trouve ça extrêmement choquant alors que
nous parlons des 2,8 millions de
personnes qui ont défilé dans la rue
aujourd'hui pour sauvegarder leur
système de retraite qu'il y ait des
rires dans la majorité et puis qu'on
nous dise pourquoi pas 4 millions
pourquoi pas 5 millions ce qui va tout à
fait d'ailleurs avec ce que disait le
gouvernement qu'on soit 700 000 ou 2
millions il n'en n'ont que faire et je
veux redire que je trouve ça très
méprisant pour des gens qui ont perdu
une journée de salaire pour aller
manifester que je trouve ça très
méprisant pour celles et ceux qui sont
en train de se demander comment ils vont
juste tenir physiquement jusqu'à 64 ans
qui vont se demander comment est-ce
qu'on va avoir une retraite juste
descente et digne avec de plus en plus
de gens qui doivent maintenant aider
leur enfant voir leur petit enfant
tellement la pauvreté explose dans notre
pays je trouve ça méprisant et je veux
je veux le dire pourquoi est-ce que nous
passons autant de temps sur cette index
parce que derrière il y a des questions
de une grande souffrance derrière quand
on est en train de parler de finir sa
carrière professionnelle au RSA au
chômage à la SS c'est de la souffrance
derrière en plus de pension qui vont
baisser donc j'aimerais qu'on arrête le
mépris du peuple et je vous le dis
méfiez-vous méfiez-vous parce que quand
il y a autant de gens qui sont opposés à
cette réforme des retraites méfiez-vous
de ce que vous êtes en train de faire et
du mépris que vous avez pour les gens et
d'ailleurs méfiez-vous tellement que je
voudrais féliciter la commission défense
qui a été saisie pour avis et qui vient
de rejeter l'article 7
[Applaudissements]
monsieur de la porte
oui non seulement je félicite la
commission défense mais je ne félicite
pas le rassemblement national pour cette
amendement finalement vite de sens évite
de fonds comme l'ensemble des
amendements qu'il propose depuis le
début sauf quand ils sont xénophobe donc
là en l'occurrence si on lit bien ce qui
est marqué son montant se fonde sur des
éléments objectifs bah oui mais pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas voté quand on vous
proposait véritablement des éléments
objectifs chers collègues du
rassemblement national parce que là vous
n'apportez rien au débat là vous là ce
que vous faites c'est de la
bordalisation pure et de l'obstruction
finalement donc voilà là des amendements
comme celui-là mais je vous en fais à
l'appel on pourrait dire des amendements
son montant se fonde sur des éléments
réels et importants on pourrait dire son
amendement se fonde sur des éléments et
c'est vrai non mais là je vous suggère
des amendements mais c'est vraiment un
amendement qui juridiquement ne tient
pas la route franchement c'est pas
sérieux surtout plus les leçons que vous
passez votre temps à donner au banc de
laupestre qui oui sont là si oui travail
kiwi travaille sur le fond donc moi
j'aimerais bien qu'on arrête ce type de
débat stérile et surtout ce type
d'accusation parce que oui je reconnais
madame que les manifestants aujourd'hui
n'étaient pas dans la rue pour la nups
mais je reconnais que la nups était là
pour eux elle était là pour eux dans la
rue et elle était là avec eux et nous
étions là parce que nous sommes contre
ce projet et ils étaient là contre ce
projet aussi et c'est finalement ce que
nous avons en partage très bien monsieur
Tachet de la Pagerie merci madame la
Présidente
je dois avouer alors tous les
amendements sont de qualité car tous les
amendements sont de valeur priority sont
tous déposés par des parlementaires qui
je crois sont tous élus de la même façon
par le peuple cela pour dire que le
principe aristocratique qu'on met au
centre du jeu monsieur Delaporte qui
vise à faire croire qu'il y a des élus
qui sont mieux que les autres des élus
qui sont mieux élus pour de meilleures
raisons que les autres qui visent à
attaquer de toute façon systématiquement
abdominale le groupe rassemblement
nation est insupportable nous accuser de
paresse par le menteur alors que nous
prenons responsabilité parce que nous
voulons débattre c'est insupportable
cette façon cette façon de se comporter
de façon puérile de façon insultante de
façon indécente et là je prends tous les
groupes à partir pas uniquement le mien
franchement de sert pas la cause ni
celle des personnes que vous dites
d'effondre dans la rue et qu'a priori
nous souhaitons tous défendre je vous
appelle vraiment un peu plus de sérieux
et de respect et d'arrêter de faire
montre de mépris vis-à-vis de nous tous
très bien bon sur ce je vais mettre au
voie donc c'est
pardon madame taillie paulion oui je
l'avais pas vu excusez-moi
ce procès je vous en prie je donne la
parole à tout le monde dès que vous me
le demandez mais par contre parfois je
vois pas une main levée c'est tout ça
peut arriver il y a du monde voilà alors
madame taille et Pollion vous avez la
parole et vous seul avez la parole je
vous remercie moi je voudrais quand même
effectivement
redire deux mots sur cet amendement qui
ne qui ne tourne pas et pardon mais
quand on emploie on met des mots les uns
à côté des autres sans qu'il n'ait aucun
sens par rapport à une réalité en fait
on produit un amendement pour produire
un amendement et c'est la réalité de cet
amendement là et quand on n'est pas
capable d'en produire plus de 75 ça fait
pas beaucoup par député et ça fait pas
de d'amendement de qualité à tel point
qu'on se demande effectivement s'il y a
une réelle volonté de s'opposer à cette
réforme parce que ce qu'on observe là
pour l'instant c'est une volonté d'aller
vite c'est une volonté de la clé un
petit peu les choses et c'est une
volonté de ne pas aller au fond des
débats tous mes collègues et moi même
nous avons déposé ses vrais de nombreux
amendements et je tiens à le dire parce
que nous considérons que ce projet de
loi doit être traité avec sérieux on a
vu dans beaucoup d'autres temps de cette
assemblée y compris très récemment des
je me souviens de la de la niche de mes
de mes collègues LFI ou effectivement on
a posé des amendements qui n'avaient
rien à voir des amendements ridicules ce
n'est pas le cas ici ce n'est pas le cas
nous sommes là sur un débat de fond et
l'index senior c'est la réalité des
seniors aujourd'hui on peut toujours se
renvoyer les chiffres
au visage mais la réalité que nous
voyons
c'est quand même celle qui a besoin
d'une politique d'une grande politique
pour faire en sorte que les personnes
expérimentées est encore accès à
l'emploi monsieur ferrati vous pouvez
toujours nous ressortir les chiffres et
nous ne lisons visiblement pas de la
même façon mais vous-même vous
reconnaissez qu'il y a besoin de cette
grande politique et vous nous proposez
un index qui ne sert à rien et vous avez
supprimé les contrats de génération en
2017 ça fait 5 ans qu'il ne se passe
rien et maintenant il se passe
presque la même chose que rien avec
cette index donc vous reconnaissez qu'il
y a un problème et vous ne faites rien
très bien donc sur ce je mets aux voix
cette amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui contre il est rejeté amendement
suivant monsieur Monet ou monsieur
d'arriville monsieur ce serait madame
Lebon allez-y madame alors il s'agit de
mieux caractériser les salariés dont il
est question dans l'article le terme
senior est trop vague nous avons besoin
d'une indication d'âge et puis je
voudrais rebondir chers collègues sur le
fait que vous nous assurez depuis hier
que non jamais au grand jamais le fait
de décaler l'âge de la retraite de
favoriser l'emploi des seniors ne va
aggraver le chômage des jeunes je vais
vous donner un seul exemple pour tenter
de vous convaincre du contraire dans mon
département la réunion nous connaissons
un fort taux de chômage à tel point que
la réforme de l'assurance chômage ne
sait pas appliquée chez nous les seniors
soient les personnes âgées de 50 à 64
ans bénéficie d'un taux d'emploi qui a
progressé depuis les dix dernières
années ce sont les chiffres de l'INSEE
alors que c'est le taux de chômage qui a
progressé chez les jeunes plus d'un
jeune sur deux est au chômage dans mon
département comment allez-vous faire
pour cette réforme ne pas l'appliquer
pour les outre-mer le nombre de
manifestants à la réunion a été
multipliée par 4 aujourd'hui par rapport
au 19 janvier cette réforme
cette réforme est impopulaire dans
l'Hexagone mais elle est
particulièrement mortifère dans les
outre-mer on y vit moins longtemps et en
moins bonne santé votre texte est une
attaque de plus contre ces populations
et elle ne s'y trompe pas
très bien
Madame la rapporteur merci alors on a
depuis le début du de cet article
Changer le mot salariés par senior donc
vous voulez faire l'inverse c'était le
seul mot Seigneur qui était dans cet
article donc c'est un avis défavorable
très bien monsieur Ferracci
oui merci madame la Présidente sur cette
question qui est intéressante légitime
consistant à savoir si le fait de
maintenir les seniors en emploi
engendrerait du chômage chez les jeunes
c'est une vraie question je pense qu'il
faut se la poser
la réponse que vous avez donné chère
collègues et bien témoigne une
représentation du marché du travail qui
n'est pas la bonne c'est l'idée que le
travail sera un gâteau qu'on se partage
l'idée que c'est un gâteau qu'on se
partage c'est une idée qui est réfutée
depuis un certain nombre d'années
maintenant par beaucoup d'études je vais
pas ici vous les donner mais on peut
continuer le débat
c'est l'idée qui sous-tend par exemple
que la réduction du temps de travail
pourra créer des emplois et on sait que
ce ne sont pas des éléments de réduction
du temps de travail qui ont créé des
emplois c'est allégement de charges qui
les ont accompagnés c'est aussi ce que
ce que recouvre la représentation du
marché du travail de l'extrême droite
quand elle dit que les immigrés viennent
prendre le travail des autochtones c'est
exactement la même représentation l'idée
du travail comme un gâteau qu'on se
partage la réalité et il se trouve que
c'est très je vais pas faire de la
promotion pour pour ma communication sur
les réseaux sociaux mais je viens de
recevoir un graphique qui montre que en
réalité quand le taux d'emploi des
seigneurs s'améliore et bien le taux de
chômage des jeunes a plutôt tendance à
baisser ça ne vaut pas causalité c'est
un bien indiqué et encore une fois c'est
ce sont des éléments sur lesquels nous
devons pouvoir débattre mais elle est
lumière de ce qu'on sait et encore une
fois le travail n'est pas un gâteau
qu'on se partage le fait de maintenir
les seneurs en emploi de pénalise pas
les jeunes
très bien monsieur Coulomme mais non
merci madame la Présidente certains
d'entre vous l'ont dit plusieurs fois
sont agriculteurs fille d'agriculteurs
certains ont peut-être des enfants qui
travaillent comme infirmière
aide-soignante ou peut-être même qui ont
de la famille qui travaille dans le
bâtiment et bien en ce qui me concerne
je viens du monde paysan ouvrière
agricole je parle ici au nom de la
classe ouvrière les ouvriers qui se sont
mobilisés avec tant d'autres dans la rue
aujourd'hui ne veulent pas de cette
réforme et vous le savez admettre que
vous avez tort serait du courage
politique de votre part
ce serait aussi
ce serait aussi du courage d'accepter
d'admettre qu'avec nos amendements nous
faisons des propositions pour avoir un
débat de fond mais vous refusez de voir
la réalité en face le travail brise les
corps parfois les esprits et nous devons
permettre à nos aînés de vivre leur
retraite en bonne santé j'ai entendu ce
matin sur une chaîne d'infos de la part
d'une députée du groupe Renaissance ce
n'est pas la rue qui viendra dicter ce
qu'il doit se passer à l'Assemblée et
bien si qui nous a élu les gens qui
étaient dans la rue aujourd'hui
vous nous demandez de retirer nos
amendements il vous demande de retirer
votre projet de réforme
[Applaudissements]
très bien monsieur jumelles
si on pouvait éviter de s'aplaudir
toutes les minutes ce serait bien quand
même
monsieur jumelles
pour pouvoir parler
non mais notre collègue c'est ratchi
semble très attentif à nous produire des
graphiques semblent avoir des références
étayées expertiser des chiffres qu'il
annonce je veux vous faire part des
nôtres pour qu'on puisse y compris
sans référer aux sources les sources
c'est le ministère du travail et du
plein emploi de l'insertion les sources
c'est une étude de la DARES d'avril 2022
et les sources c'est une étude de
l'INSEE
consolidée sur l'emploi une enquête de
2016 que fait-elle apparaître
elle fait apparaître que le taux
d'emploi descend à 35,5% pour les 60 64
ans et chute même à 8,6% entre 65 et 69
ans démonstration est faite quand
reculant l'âge de départ en retraite
vous accentuez évidemment ce phénomène
deuxième élément sur le type d'emploi
occupé par les seniors sur le type
d'emploi occupé par des Sénats les CDI
semble être la règle Maillard arrêtait
de rire bêtement
député
les CD semble être la règle pour 90% des
personnes
âgées de 50 ans néanmoins
6,1% des 55 64 ans
occupe un emploi en situation de
sous-emploi c'est à dire à temps partiel
ou en chômage technique ou partielle
6,7 de ceux qui sont salariés sont en
contrat temporaire intérim ou CDD y
compris en quoi saisonnier ou aider
22,9% de l'emploi des 50 5 64 ans est un
emploi à temps partiel contre 18,7% pour
l'ensemble des catégories tout cela
démontre que nous sommes et le président
Macron l'avait reconnu lui-même le
dernier élève de l'Europe en matière
d'emploi des seigneurs le en quoi votre
texte à la noix de coco répond à ces
questions là
[Musique]
lui seul à la parole s'il vous plaît on
essaie commandement s'il vous plaît
monsieur Bazin merci madame la
Présidente
moi je suis très attentif à une des
interventions
qui venus de la nupes concernant
l'outre-mer et je pense qu'on a un vrai
point de vigilance sur la réforme des
retraites sur ce point-là parce qu'on a
quand même des spécificités en outre-mer
je pense aux travailleurs agricoles en
Guadeloupe et à la Réunion je pense
aussi à la question à Mayotte du régime
obligatoire de retraite où on a
effectivement des spécificités liées au
travail et on peut pas déconnecter la
question de la retraite de la question
du travail et c'est vrai que là on est
sur un PLFSS où on n'a pas un titre
spécifique sur l'adaptation des mesures
à l'Outre-mer pour autant et c'est un
peu le problème du véhicule qui est un
peu les fesses rectificatif on n'a pas
le paquet mesure relatives au travail il
va falloir qu'on puisse prendre en
compte ces spécificités
et je pense que c'est un vrai point de
vigilance là-dessus le ministre la
semaine dernière en réponse à des
questions au Gouvernement sur le sujet a
dit un chantier est en cours est-ce que
très concrètement
d'ici la séance on aura des articles
additionnels du gouvernement là-dessus
je sais pas si vous avez des échanges
par rapport à ce point madame la
rapporteur est-ce que
en séance il pourra avoir des
amendements gouvernementaux qui
précisent et qui concrétise ces
chantiers on imagine bien il y a tout le
sujet de la convergence mais en même
temps il y a le sujet des réalités avec
parfois des assiettes de cotisations qui
n'étaient pas celles là et en même temps
des taux d'emplois qui ne sont pas au
rendez-vous plus pour Mayotte une
spécificité alors je le sais parce que
Mansour camardine et dans notre groupe
on est souvent sur 9 années cotisées
seulement et donc on est quand même très
loin des modèles tels qu'on les a
imaginés il faut aussi qu'on puisse
apporter une réponse pour ceux qui ont
travaillé ceux qui travaillent et qui
travailleront là je suis toujours avec
ce champ valorisation du travail et
pérennité du système mais en même temps
il faut qu'on puisse apporter cette
réponse spécifique et c'est un vrai
point de préoccupation
très bien Monsieur Paul Christophe oui
merci Présidente je voulais simplement
compléter les propos de Marc ferrachi au
sujet du chômage des jeunes puisque le
corps donc je peux probable la causalité
entre chômage des plus jeunes et emploie
des seniors pour justifier ce diagnostic
ces experts mettent en avant la
différence des postes occupés entre
jeunes et seniors et pour le Conseil
l'emploi des seniors ne détériore pas la
situation professionnelle des jeunes il
va même plus loin puisqu'il trouve des
bénéfices au phénomène et je cite les
économies réalisées par la poursuite de
l'activité par les plus âgées
permettrait de limiter donc la hausse
des cotisations pesant sur les
générations suivantes et donc au final
de favoriser l'emploi des plus jeunes
celui en limitant le coût des charges et
le besoin d'épargne je pense que ça
méritait d'être précisé très bien pour
cette précision monsieur turquois
oui merci Madame président moi j'ai
entendu des justement des interventions
et qui qui sur des constats je peux en
partager
mais c'est sur la réponse qui est donnée
qui me qui me va pas quand monsieur
jumelles parle d'un taux d'emploi qui
est faible pour les seniors mais c'est
une réalité on a été une société qui a
massivement fait des salariés les plus
âgés une variable d'ajustement par des
programmes de pré-tête massif par des
départs volontaires et donc comment on
remet la culture de valoriser ses
compétences plutôt que s'en priver
premier élément deuxième élément on a eu
des discussions qui opposent entre il y
a notre collègue qui a dit qui est
relevé du salariat salariat agricole et
je l'entends certains
moi je pense que le travail peut
permettre une réalisation de l'individu
peut permettre
un accomplissement mais j'entends aussi
le discours
j'entends aussi le discours que il y a
des métiers qui peuvent être pénibles
qui peuvent être durs et qui peuvent
user comment
j'aimerais finir comment peut-on comment
peut-on changer le rapport au travail
comment peut-on au lieu d'avoir des gens
usés à 58 ou à 60 ans on puisse
peut-être à 40 ou 45 ans proposer une
réorientation et puis il y a eu
l'outre-mer et ça je vous le dis j'ai
pas une expertise particulière même pas
une expertise du tout des outre-mer par
contre force c'est de constater que le
taux de chômage des jeunes sur dans les
outre-mer c'est c'est un gâchis aussi
comme j'ai pu parler et donc on est une
politique spécifique pour des
territoires qui le sont sur lequel nous
devons travailler au développement de
l'emploi ça a du sens mais je vous
invite tous toutes et tous à réfléchir
comment préserve ce système qui a des
imperfections mais qui si nous n'y
prenons pas garde va
aboutir à sa disparition dans les dans
les prochaines années très bien alors
avant de faire la pause je donne la
parole à Monsieur califer qui me l'a
demandé on passe au vote et ensuite je
vais suspendre et on reprendra à 21h15
monsieur califer
je vous donne le micro oui merci
j'aime bien quand on parle de notre mère
on a oublié notre mère et quand notre
meilleur parle de l'outre-mer ça semble
intéressé personne
ça semble intéressé personne la preuve
de ce que nous votons le budget de notre
mère nous sommes presque seuls et même
seul dans l'hémicycle et quand
d'aventure
et que d'aventure nous exposons nos
problématiques il faut voir les
hochements de tête et parfois les
mimiques effectivement
vous voyez
la démonstration écoutez nous avons tous
les soucis du monde mais nous sommes
dans la République
une république qui a abandonné depuis
des lustres ces territoires là
et qui n'a fait qu'empiler mesures sur
mesure pour complexifier le
développement de ces territoires là et
laissez des hydrolat aux mains de
monopole qui ont leur entrée à l'Élysée
sans difficulté depuis l'illustre je
vous dis depuis des lustres ne pas et
comprendre que ça ça date de maintenant
nous avons des molécules qui ont été
suspendues arrêtés interdit partout sauf
sur nos territoires
et quand on le dit et bien vous regardez
encore ce sont un sourire sois mimique
comme si t'es pas important et là nous
parlons des hommes et des femmes comment
voulez-vous que dans nos territoires ou
qu'il n'y a pas de développement qui va
embaucher et pourquoi on peut faire tout
ce qu'on veut pour les aînés mettre des
index même mettre des majeurs
cela ne va rien nommer de plus si on ne
touche pas véritablement au
développement de ces territoires là et
c'est ce qu'on vous demande parfois
cette solidarité là nous sommes en train
de parler froidement avec des tableaux
avec des graphiques alors que derrière
tout cela il y a des hommes et des
femmes et je suis heureux qu'on puisse
le dire et quand c'est du bon monsieur
Bazin ça passe mieux mais moi je le dis
avec ma passion avec la douleur de ceux
qui m'a envoyé ici merci à vous très
bien
très bien voilà pas besoin d'applaudir
on est on est d'accord on partage les
territoires d'outre-mer on les aime
sachez-le monsieur le député très bien
alors donc du coup je mets aux voix
cette amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de Madame la rapporteur qui
est pour qui est contre il est rejeté
mes chers collègues je vous souhaite un
excellent appétit et je vous retrouve à
21h15 merci